hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast the august 2021 ask me anything
episode i'm your host sean carroll you
know how this works probably by now uh
it's an ask me anything so people write
questions and i do my best to answer
them the people who get to answer the
ques to ask the questions are patreon
supporters so if you want to be part of
the question asking brigade just join up
at patreon.com
sean m carroll not that expensive and
you get not only the right to ask
questions every month for the amas but
also you get ad-free versions of the
podcast and a feeling of well-being for
supporting something good and being
member of a community now as we've said
before the questions of uh the number of
questions has grown fairly large so we
cannot answer all of them but
i go through and i try to figure out
which ones i have interesting things to
say about so again if you don't get your
question answered not necessarily
because your question wasn't good it
just didn't vibe or resonate with what i
had to say in this particular day
um so i hope everyone's doing well we're
in the middle of the summer
post 2020 so the first summer that
should be post-pandemic but we're not
postpandemic because many people have
not gotten vaccinated yet and therefore
we're still in the middle of a pandemic
and
i hope that it doesn't get worse but as
long as uh we haven't vaccinated the
whole world there's still plenty of
opportunities for the virus to mutate we
already have the delta variant and other
things and rather than just getting rid
of this virus we're sort of letting it
flit from person to person because we
don't want to as a society take the
necessary steps to fix it this makes me
very sad but nevertheless uh several
months ago i decided i was just going to
be optimistic about this and therefore
i've made travel plans so tomorrow as i
record this ama episode will be the
first time i go to the airport to step
on an airplane in roughly a year and a
half so we'll see how that goes i'm
going to santa fe to go to the santa fe
institute where i am now officially a
fractal faculty member that's the big
news of this month in my life um
some of you know that i am an external
professor had been an external professor
at santa fe actually some of you might
not even know the santa fe institute is
it's a research institute in santa fe
dedicated to the study of complex
systems which is an area i'm very much
getting into these days and so
most of the people who are involved with
santa fe in some way or another actually
don't live and work there they live and
work somewhere else but they visit there
regularly and so there's a category
called external professors where
in return for being able to say i am
affiliated with the santa fe institute
uh you promise to do something for them
like you know help them choose post docs
or organize a conference or spend some
time there or whatever it is
so i've been there for a couple years i
didn't get really to take advantage of
it because we've had a pandemic for the
last year and a half but now this
upgrade to fractal fractal faculty means
that it's just more of an obligation so
i will go several weeks a year at least
six weeks every year spend time in santa
fe um and you know really take part in
what goes on there i'm going into
details here because someone asked a
question i didn't include in the ama but
here's the answer what does it mean to
be an external professor at the santa fe
institute it just means you do research
that is involved with santa fe you spend
time there you talk to people i've
already been on many zoom meetings etc
with people at santa fe even though i
haven't been physically there
and i'm very proud to be one of the
first two fractal faculty members in
existence the other one is melanie
mitchell former mindscape podcast guest
an expert in artificial intelligence and
uh computing more generally she was
remembered douglas hofstadter's graduate
student back in the day um so melanie
and i are the first two fractal faculty
and it'll be fun you know it's it's one
of those places sfi where
every time i go i am just energized with
all the ideas that are bouncing around
because some people are thinking about
physics and thermodynamics other people
are thinking about economics other
people are thinking about linguistics or
the origin of life and it's just you
know kid in a candy store feeling for
myself um so that'll be for two weeks
i'm gonna go to santa fe and then i'm
gonna come back to la for two weeks and
then i'm spending the fall on sabbatical
at harvard
as a visitor in the harvard philosophy
department i'm sure i'm going to
also talk to some physicists while i'm
there i have many friends in the physics
department and astronomy department at
harvard
but i want i was a grad student there
but i want to really start thinking more
deeply about questions of emergence and
causation
and the nature of the laws of physics
humanism and things like that so i
thought that would be a very uh a
wonderful place to do that and of course
um
uh not only is harvard a very good place
but it's near other good places so i can
talk to a whole bunch of people they
have official visitors program and i
applied and i was invited to go do that
so that's where i'll be for september
october november so that's also another
travel thing i hope goes well like if i
end up sitting in an apartment in boston
and just zooming with people at harvard
that won't be fun so please get
vaccinated please get yourself
some immunity much much greater immunity
to the effects of this terrible disease
so that we can get over the pandemic and
return to normal life and with that
let's go
[Music]
arthur c quark
probably not their real name says in the
big picture you describe the fine-tuning
argument like this in bayesian language
the likelihood of life appearing in the
universe might be larger under theism
than under naturalism
then we can therefore conclude that our
very existence is strong evidence in
favor of theism in addition to
everything you mentioned to decrement
its credibility the argument itself
feels wrong if i mad lib the argument i
can prove that i'm psychic or that bear
taxes makes bear goes away bears go away
is the argument itself a logical fallacy
in bayesian language the likelihood of
me winning the lottery might be large
under i'm psychic and small under i'm
not psychic we can therefore conclude
that my winning lottery is strong
evidence in favor of me being psychic
so the answer to this is you're not
quite being a very good bayesian yet
arthur sorry about that
this is how bayesian's reason so for one
thing don't use the word prove you said
i can prove i'm psychic no you can't
prove you're psychic but you can gather
evidence that you're psychic and you can
gather evidence against that you're
psychic and you count it all up okay
the point of me making this argument was
that you know it was not to show that
the fine-tuning argument works because i
don't think it does work it's to show
that if that's all you knew about the
universe was the life existed then you
could count that as evidence uh for the
existence of god because there is a
likelihood function and i don't think
that
it's unreasonable to think that the
likelihood of life under theism is
larger than the likelihood of life under
naturalism i i that's completely
reasonable and you just have to take the
argument seriously you have to take
bayesian analysis seriously so for one
thing there's a prior of course if your
prior is very small for one possibility
or the other that will swamp any one
piece of evidence that you have um but
more importantly there's other evidence
out there and that's what really matters
a good bayesian will admit that there
are certain facts about the world that
favor even the wrong hypotheses right i
mean if you think about all the
hypotheses you could make about the
world and then focus in on the subset
where some people actually believe these
hypotheses
it's overwhelmingly likely that there
are certain aspects of the world
that are better explained by these wrong
hypotheses than by the right ones a
priori right because otherwise no one
would believe the wrong hypotheses
but to be a good bazi and you have to
take all of the evidence into account
and that this is the mistake that is
made by people who put forward the
fine-tuning argument in my mind is that
they focus in on one fact that there's
life in the universe and they say the
likelihood of life under theism is
greater than likelihood of life under
atheism and my point is if you want to
play that game which is a perfectly
legitimate game to play you have to look
at other aspects of the universe and say
are those other aspects of the universe
more likely under theism or atheism and
the reason why they don't want to do
that is that over and over again
the aspects that we observe about the
universe are way more likely under
naturalism than under atheism
than under theism so
when you say the likelihood of me
winning lottery might be large under i'm
psychic and small under i'm not psychic
we can therefore conclude that my
winning lottery is strong evidence in
favor of me being psychic
yes it is pretty strong evidence in
favor of you being psychic now there
might be plenty of other evidence that
you are not psychic but think of it this
way what if you just thought of what the
right lottery number was going to be and
played it and won
five times in a row
you might say well hey actually that is
pretty good evidence that i'm psychic if
i can consistently win a billion to one
odds lottery maybe there is something
going on there right but if you can if
that's true when you do it five times in
a row or ten times in a row then there's
some evidence in that favor even if you
only do it once
that evidence need not be so good that
you believe the hypothesis a good
bayesian never puts their credence to
zero or one for any reasonable
hypothesis so it moves your credence
whatever amount but that doesn't mean
that you're done that doesn't mean that
you uh can stop thinking i think it's
very very important to really take
seriously the fact that you can't play
the bayesian game only on the evidence
you like you have to play it on all of
the evidence that is the point of that
argument i was making in the big picture
brendan hall says does general
relativity become greatly different when
one analyzes say four spatial dimensions
to make 5d space-time as opposed to
three so the short answer is no it's not
really all that different general
relativity in higher numbers of
dimensions but the reason why it's an
interesting question is because
interestingly general relativity is very
different in two spatial dimensions so
if you have three dimensional space time
there is kind of a phase transition
one-dimensional general relativity or
two-dimensional general relativity are
very different than general relativity
in four five six etc dimensions
is this some kind of anthropic argument
that we need at least three spatial
dimensions to make the world interesting
probably not but i'm just throwing it
out there for you and actually let me
just take this advantage take advantage
of this opportunity to go into a little
bit more technical detail that i would
usually go into here because it is a
very interesting subject what is the way
in which in what sense is general
relativity different in two-dimensional
space so three-dimensional space-time
rather than the real world
well
the and i can't help but introduce the
jargon here sorry about that we often
say that general relativity says that
matter and energy in the universe drive
the curvature of space-time that's
probably what you've heard you've heard
me say it if no one else but there's it
turns out there are different types of
curvature in space-time and this is just
a mathematical fact and i'm not really
going to explain the different types but
there are two different types and one is
called the richie curvature named after
professor ritchie who's an italian
geometer
and the other is called the vile
curvature named after hermann vile who
is a german mathematician uh vile
w-e-y-l okay
so these there are these two different
types of curvature and they're both
bundled up into the riemann curvature
the riemann tensor is the geometric
object in general relativity that tells
you all the curvature and different
pieces of the riemann tensor correspond
to the vial curvature or the richie
curvature
and the point is that einstein's
equation which relates the curvature of
space time to matter and energy says two
things it says that the richie curvature
of space-time that part of the curvature
is exactly determined by the
distribution of energy and momentum okay
so if you tell me what the energy is i
instantly know what the richie curvature
is that's a geometric
and so i should say an algebraic
relation that is given to us by
einstein's equation of general
relativity tell me the energy i'll tell
you the richie curvature whereas the
vile curvature is not completely fixed
by the amount of energy and momentum in
fact what einstein's equations tell you
is that there is an equation that
relates the evolution
of the vile curvature
but it doesn't tell you what the initial
conditions are so that's crucially
important for general relativity because
the vile curvature characterizes things
like gravitational waves when you have a
gravitational wave propagating in empty
space
if i just tell you well space is empty
there's no energy and momentum there
that doesn't tell you whether there's a
gravitational wave there or not right
telling you what the energy momentum is
in in in some part of the universe has
nothing to do with whether or not
there's a gravitational wave if it did
then there couldn't be any gravitational
waves right because in empty space there
wouldn't be anything to source them but
the gravitational waves are vile
curvature which are not fixed their
evolution is governed but the initial
conditions are not fixed by einstein's
equation so why am i telling you all
this well because the way the math works
out there is no such thing as vile
curvature in three dimensional space
time it just goes away it's just zero
identically there is only richie
curvature
so in
three-dimensional space-time there are
no gravitational waves there is no
curvature of space outside matter right
so it becomes a little bit more
interesting to think about how gravity
would work in three-dimensional
space-time and
in fact i've written papers about it
if you have a cosmic string which is
infinitely long and perfectly straight
then along the direction of
the in which the cosmic string is
pointing you can just ignore everything
that happens there's a symmetry with
respect to boosts and translations in
that direction so a set of cosmic
strings that are infinitely long
perfectly straight and parallel to each
other are equivalent to point particles
in one lower dimensional space time you
just ignore the dimension along the
strings pointing
so you can actually analyze questions of
cosmic strings in a two plus one
dimensional three-dimensional that is
space-time context and that makes things
easier and the reason why that's
interesting is because richard gott of
princeton pointed out that you can build
closed time-like curves using infinitely
long straight cosmic strings so alan
guth and eddy fari and ken olum and i
analyzed that question uh using this two
plus one dimensional point particle uh
version of the problem the spherical cow
version of the problem and we showed
that uh if you had a time machine built
into the universe it would stay there
but you can't build it if it's not there
to start gerard tuft also wrote some
things along those lines so anyway all
of which is to say uh gravity is
different in two or three-dimensional
space-time four or more is more or less
the same up to some details
dave williams says
priority question i recently oh remember
that's right so priority questions are i
said that
everyone gets one priority question in
their lifetime
and i it's the honors system here i'm
not keeping track of when asks these
questions but in your you get to ask one
priority question as a patreon supporter
that i promise i will answer i don't
promise i will give you an answer that
you will like or will satisfy you but i
promise i will answer here in the ama so
dave williams says i recently posed
myself a question suppose i journeyed a
thousand kilometers in 10 hours but on
arrival i was only doing 40 kilometers
an hour those that greeted me only knew
i'd traveled a thousand kilometers and i
arrived 40 kilometers an hour hence they
thought i took 25 hours when actually i
took 10.
such a trip mimics our observations of
the universe i easily saw the dilemma of
conflicting journey times by assuming
that the product of the distance and the
time was a constant translating this
idea to the universe and interpreting
our observations in this matter solves
all the problems inflation dark matter
etc
uh has anyone ever thought of this is
roughly the question so um you know the
short
strategy the simple strategy you should
use in these situations is to think to
yourself you know
are decades of very smart professional
scientists complete dummies or not and
the answer is no they are not complete
dummies so this assumption that the
expansion of the universe is just
constant or you can just extrapolate
what you see in your local neighborhood
no one ever made that assumption that
would be a dopey assumption to make what
we do is two things number one we
predict the evolution of the expansion
rate of the universe using einstein's
equation of general relativity and then
we test those predictions okay so we
test those predictions with the
microwave background with redshifts with
the nucleosynthesis in the very very
early universe and there's a
relationship between the density of the
universe and its expansion rate that is
predicted by einstein and so far that
relationship fits all of the
experimental
data it passes all the tests and the
other thing from a model independent
theory independent point of view is we
just measure it so that's how the
acceleration of the universe was
measured it was not by
looking at the measure the expansion
rate of the universe here in our local
region and is extrapolating it you
measured the expansion rate of the
universe at different eras you can do
that using the relationship between
distance and velocity so um and that's
where all the problems come from so all
these problems dark matter dark energy
etc are because we don't make that
assumption they're not solved by
unmaking that assumption
justin bailey says is there a minimum
speed of light at which the universe is
still interesting i.e has beings like us
what would that universe be like
i'm going to unask this question a
little bit
because
there's a different lesson to be learned
here um well when you say minimum speed
of light in what units do you mean like
meters per second
uh if the speed of light were different
everything else would be different also
it's essentially meaningless
to say if the speed of light were
different the speed of light is always
one light year per year that's the only
natural units you can measure it in
anything else is just invented by human
beings because at the speed of light
we're different the size of the hydrogen
atom would be different right all the
rulers you used to measure things would
be different so i can always literally
always choose units in which the speed
of light is one
and then so what you're really asking is
if i choose units where the speed of
light is one it's there's no such thing
as the speed of light being big or small
right it's the fact that there is a
speed limit that matters we can always
choose units where that speed limit is
one and then you can ask about changing
other dimensionless unitless constants
of nature the fine structure constant
the ratio of the mass of the proton to
the mass of the electron and things like
that okay so the right question to ask
when you're asking questions about other
ways the universe could have been
is to change dimensionless quantities
quantities that do not have a unit
attached to them like meters or
kilograms or meters per second any one
of those depends on the units a ratio
like i said of the mass of the proton to
the mass of the electron that's the same
no matter what units you use so that
could change the speed of light is a
speed
a velocity right meters per second and
there are no other speeds in the
fundamental laws of physics so there's
no ratio you can take to get a
dimensionless number so you just can't
imagine a universe literally where the
speed of light was anything else other
than infinity infinity is sort of a you
know a limiting case there right so the
right question to ask is how can you
change other quantities of nature and
still have beings like us
and uh that's a hard question that's
that's one i don't know the answer to
people have thought about it but you
know it depends a lot on your
assumptions and our calculational
abilities which are not very good
but larka k says is dark matter
discussed or framed as a limit in to our
knowledge in physics
you know in some simple way it is
because we don't know what it is we
don't we know that there is dark matter
we know where it is to some rough
approximation we know how much of it
there is we know how it behaves uh we
don't know what actually is
making up the dark matter so yeah that's
a limit to our knowledge in physics it's
not framed as a limit that is in
principle there we could easily discover
what the dark matter is what if it's a
particle or something else you know
that's something we're trying to do very
very hard so it's definitely not a
limited principle it's just a question
we haven't answered yet which science is
full of those
johnny says at a base level are photons
much different than any other matter
particle apologies for the basic
question here um
you know it depends what you mean there
are certain ways in which photons are
different than other kinds of particles
and certain ways in which they're the
same
for any way that they're different
there's probably other particles that
are the same as them right so the most
obvious difference between particles uh
the photons and electrons let's say is
that photons are massless and they move
at the speed of light but gravitons are
also massless they move at the speed of
light gluons are massless they would
move at the speed of light if they could
escape by themselves and just travel
through space but they can't because
they're confined in uh
in strongly interacting particles um so
that's a basic difference but it's you
know again gravitons are the same way so
it's not a unique difference
photons have zero electric charge but
then again so do neutrinos so do
gravitons also photons have spin one but
then again so do w bosons and z bosons
and gluons right so you get the point uh
photons are different than any other
specific kind of particle but they're
not different than all the other
particles combined in the sense that
everything that is different about
between a photon and one other kind of
particle will be a similarity between a
photon and some other particle
carlos nunez says who is your favorite
superhero and why
um you know i i'm pretty agnostic about
the superheroes these days although i'm
a fan of the movies i like the movies
but i'm not a
a huge comic book fan like uh i was
never actually probably a huge comic
book fan i was a medium sized comic book
fan when i was a kid right and back then
my favorite heroes probably still today
are
the sort of most
magical ones so i liked uh dr strange
right doctor strange by the way and for
recent mindscape listeners one of our
early interviews was with scott
derrickson who is the director and
co-writer of doctor strange the movie so
we got some insight there into the movie
um thor is another one as an asgardian
god on the dc side green lantern who
could do all these crazy things it was a
member uh you know a member of the green
lantern corps and the guardian of the
galaxies uh no not the guardians of the
galaxy right the guardians of oahu i see
i'm forgetting my uh my youthful
knowledge here but anyway yeah i like
those sort of way out superheroes more
than the down-to-earth ones like batman
or iron man or captain america or
something like that
why yeah i don't know i don't know why i
figure if you're gonna be a superhero
let's do it all the way like superman is
obviously very very powerful but the
powers are kind of boring right i mean
invulnerability you can fly okay good i
want interesting powers like i want
magical powers basically that's what i
want i think that's what my
psychoanalysis here is teaching me what
i really want out of life is magical
powers and i'm sad that the world
doesn't work that way
sam buck says careful viewers of the
veritasium youtube channel may have
noticed a cameo from you in a recent
video featuring a bet between derrick
mueller and professor alex cosenko
although sadly we never saw or heard
much from you during the event can you
talk a bit about what your experience
being a witness to the contest were you
like bill nye persuaded by professor
gosenko's presentation or surprised by
the outcome of the bet so some of you
might not know this at all but it's kind
of a fun story so veritasium is a very
good youtube channel uh run by derek
mueller and who i've appeared on some of
the little videos that you can look them
up maybe not maybe not the best most
interesting ones but there i am um and
alex kusenko is a professor of physics
at ucla and another friend of mine
and derek did a video where he traveled
in a you know what looks like a pretty
straightforward sale plane i shouldn't
say plane what should i call it like
sail car right like it's unsalt flats
and it's a thing that people built and
has little wheels and a giant sail and a
fan
and
actually doesn't even have a sail maybe
not just a fan the fan is sort of acting
like the sail but the point is that the
fan is hooked up to the wheels in such a
way
that
what is interesting is that the
the sail car i'm going to call it that
it travels toward the wind
and it can travel so fast the claim is
that it's actually going faster than the
wind is okay so if you might know if you
know sailing at all sailing on the ocean
you can go at an angle to an oncoming
wind and you can actually tack overall
toward the wind but the point the claim
here was that this particular sail car
uh plane car propeller car i should call
it was moving exactly toward the wind
and was going faster than the wind was
pushing it in the other direction so um
alex said nope that's not possible it
violates the laws of physics so they
made a bet the two of them ten thousand
dollar bet i hope i'm describing it
correctly because honestly i didn't i
didn't follow it too closely so the
reason why i didn't follow too closely
was
derek asked me if i would be a witness
to the contest so what that means is
they made a bet and the thing is you
have to trust both of them
because there wasn't any
outside panel of jury
or jury that would actually judge who
won the bet you were trusting that
through the force of reason and through
talking about it back and forth one of
them would convince the other one that
they were right that this violated laws
of physics or it didn't now you might
say if they did the experiment it
couldn't violate the laws of physics but
you know experiments are tricky right
you can always cheat a little bit and so
alex in particular thought that what
happened was
uh the plane the sail car propeller car
prop car had been accelerated but then
the um velocity of the wind temporarily
dipped down so that it seemed like the
car was going faster than the wind um
anyway so the point being that uh they
bet each other ten thousand dollars and
they said well we need witnesses to the
bent so bill nye neil degrasse tyson and
i served as witnesses to the bench so
they did a little youtube video where
alex and
derek pitched their cases to the
witnesses but sadly just because of
scheduling
conflicts i couldn't make it so that's
why
there's a little cameo there from me but
bill nye and neil degrasse tyson were
there
on the video but the point is that our
job was not to judge who's right or
wrong it was literally just to witness
the bet in fact i told derek i said if
you want me to judge who's right and
who's wrong then i'm not gonna do it
because i know perfectly well this is
exactly the kind of physics i'm terrible
at
real world stuff like moving cars and
wind and friction and air resistance and
all this stuff i have enormous respect
for the people who do that kind of thing
professionally and it's not what i do
you know i try to figure out the
ultimate laws of physics if they're
making a bit about quantum mechanics i'd
be all over that
but derek assured me that all i had to
do was literally witness you know so to
keep them honest that they were doing it
um and to be honest you know since i saw
the video the original video that alex
objected to i thought probably it was
fine like i i was i'm very willing to
believe that in complicated real world
situations the intuition of a physicist
can go sadly wrong and eventually as as
many of you know alex
conceded the bet and paid ten thousand
dollars to a charity of uh derek's
choice so that's a lot of money i
wouldn't
bet that much money but um you know so i
didn't i i had no i honestly didn't even
follow in detail the arguments back and
forth like i said that's not what i do
it's not what i'm good at i'm not
especially interested in following that
i'm happy
that both of the participants in the bet
stuck to the high ground and you know
used the force of reason to figure out
what was going on rather than just being
uh you know stubbornly sticking to their
incorrect position
linear mizyara says in your lectures
about the higgs boson in the great
courses
you said that because the w and z
particles are originally massless these
particles have to always be moving and
that is how nature knows they are left
handed however isn't movement relative
what about those particles relative to
which the z and w are stationary so to
go back to what we just said about
photons a little bit before
when the z and w were massless they were
moving at the speed of light
and that fact is not relative i mean
that's the whole point of special
relativity is that the to say that
something is moving at the speed of
light is a non-relative statement it's
an absolutely universal statement if
something's moving the speed of light
it's just moving at the speed of light
um
literally you have to be on top of it at
the same place to say oh i don't see it
moving at all but then time doesn't pass
for you so you don't say anything at all
okay
so to any other thing in the universe
you're moving at the speed of light and
that's why you can
you can
point out the direction in which it's
moving it is always moving along some
direction and then in that direction
it's either spinning left-handed or
right-handed
mikolaj zabo says is it true that
current quantum computers are not the
eniacs or edvacs of quantum computation
but more like babbage's analytical
engine
is even this a stretch
what are the chances that quantum
computing won't work in the end as
wolfram predicted in your interview with
him
i don't know if the analogies are just
very good in this case it's not that
it's it is eniac or babbage's analytical
engine is just a different thing because
back in those days you know
number one we didn't really have a
theory of computation that was very good
and number two we didn't have other
computers that worked they were trying
to build the first computers building
the first quantum computers is putting
together two great tastes that taste
great together but are individually
perfectly good quantum mechanics and
computers okay computers work quantum
mechanics works
i think that there's
essentially zero chance that quantum
computing won't work in some deep
principled physics reason i think it's
perfectly possible that quantum
computing will be not as exciting as we
hoped because of some practical
technological reason right if it just
becomes too difficult to connect enough
qubits with a short enough interaction
time between them and enough reliability
etc then it will be you know possible to
build a quantum computer but so
prohibitively expensive that no one will
do it i don't think that's likely but i
think it's conceivable i don't think uh
i don't remember exactly what stephen
wolfram was saying but i don't think
there's anything lurking in the
fundamental laws of physics that
prevents quantum computers in principle
robin van dyke says my question is about
how you come up with ideas for writing a
paper
is it just by talking with other
physicists about your work or are there
other things that influence what you
write papers about
uh yeah there's lots of things you know
there's no
it's exactly like asking a novelist
where they come up with ideas right
there's no algorithm there's no recipe
you don't just plug in and say i would
like an idea now
of course you talk to other physicists
you read other people's papers you look
you go to their talks you go to
conferences you talk to your students
and your colleagues and your postdocs uh
you read books you read things elsewhere
and you just think right you just
sometimes you just sit and think about
the puzzles that you have been bothered
by for a long time and you know the the
problem is never coming across a puzzle
the problem is coming up with an idea
that is sufficiently
promising to answer a puzzle or to
address a question that you can push it
forward in some practical way right i
mean it's easy to come up with questions
it's easy to propose answers it's hard
to come up with answers that are you
know we don't know enough about it that
it's worth doing work on but
nevertheless we can imagine making
progress on it right that's the crucial
sweet spot in there you want a problem
that is not necessarily solvable but at
least progress can be made in some sense
okay in the next two questions i'm going
to group together they're about
gravitons stu haynes says i believe
you've said that we can be a bit loose
and describe gravity as a force even
though it is really the curvature of
space-time if so why do we speak of
gravitons as a particle mediating the
force of gravity
peter solfest says are gravitons merely
the particle duality of gravitational
waves if not why is there so much
confidence that they exist
actually i'm going to stick another one
more question in here in this grouping
andrew jewell says there are four forces
with gravity and electromagnetism
there's a simple formula to calculate
the force and plug into f equals m a but
with the weak and strong forces there
are simply strange phrases such as is
involved in radioactive decay and never
an equation so what does force mean with
the strong and weak forces is there a
way to calculate an f which which can
equal m a okay so all very good
questions uh in the sense that i have
answers to them that's always a favorite
situation to be in
so um why do we speak of gravitons as a
particle mediating the force of gravity
well you can speak about the same thing
in two different languages right so that
was for stu's question for peter's
question are gravitons merely the
particle duality of gravitational waves
uh yes that's what they are so
there is the limit if you like of
physical reality where
waves in either gravity or an
electromagnetism are big classical
things
and in that limit it is perfectly
sensible to treat these things as
classical fields the gravitational field
the electric field the magnetic field
ripples in these different fields are
what we're talking about and you're in
the macroscopic world and you can use f
equals m a and you can have an equation
and figure out the force moving around a
particle
the particle-like nature of these forces
comes about when you get down to the
quantum mechanical level so when you're
just talking about a little tiny bit of
the force right when you're
measuring just one little packet of
energy for photons that's easy to do we
can see spots on a crt screen or
something like that for gravitons the
force is too weak so technologically we
can't do that but the point is there is
a regime in which it's perfectly
sensible to think of these guys as
particles there's another regime in
which it's perfectly sensible to think
of them as big classical fields giving
rise to big classical forces
at least that's the case for both
gravity and electromagnetism because
these are long range forces for the
strong and weak forces to andrew's
question there is no long-range limit
okay they can't pile up because they're
short-range forces they just don't
stretch over that large of a distance so
you never reach this limit where you
have a big macroscopic
strong nuclear force field or weak
nuclear force field this just never
happens in the physical world
but
at that quantum level there's a huge
amount of similarity between the strong
force the weak force the electromagnetic
force the gravitational force there are
equations and the equations are very
very much alike for all those four
different possibilities but it's just
that the big classical limit doesn't
exist because the short the forces are
such
are so are so short range is what i'm
trying to say um so
should you call them forces then the
strong weak forces ah i don't care i
honestly just don't care but they are
very analogous to electromagnetism and
gravity so in that sense i see why
someone would call them forces uh but
you're right we don't actually just take
a particle and and
plug it into an equation and say here is
the force but you could
for either the strong force or the weak
force before the problem is that
equation would just never apply to any
big macroscopic thing that's why you
don't actually see it in everyday life
felix roswell says is there a one-to-one
ratio of electrons to protons in the
universe
or in other words is there a net charge
to the universe so i'm going to undo the
second half of your question a little
bit
because
well i'm going to
separate these questions it's not in
other words because of course there are
other particles that have electric
charge right muons have electric charge
so you know muons can decay into
electrons neutrinos and antineutrinos or
vice versa i can smash an electron and a
positron together
and get a
muon and anti-muon
so i can change the number of electrons
without changing the number of protons
so there's not exactly
a one-to-one ratio of electrons to
protons but if what you're really asking
is is there a net charge to the universe
well we don't know is the short answer
there's very few questions about the
universe as a whole to which we know
definitive answers but most of us think
there is no net charge to the universe
there's a theorem that says that if
space is closed so if the spatial slices
of the universe are spheres or a taurus
or something like that then there can't
be a net charge then there has to be
zero net charge that's a consequence of
gauss's law or something like that so um
but if the universe is open yeah then
you could imagine a universe with a net
charge there it becomes trickier and we
just don't know anonymous says i really
enjoyed your discussion the last ama
about the difference between being a
public intellectual and being an
activist i thought about it some more
and i realized that the two roles aren't
completely disconnected an intellectual
whose conclusions aren't just
just aren't palatable to the average
person's sense of decency won't be seen
as very credible
an activist whose conclusions just
aren't realistic won't be seen as
credible either suppose that an
intellectual needs to think like an
activist sometimes where would you set
the boundary between staying in touch
with the society we live in on a basic
level and letting personal feelings and
wishes get in the way of objectivity so
this is a very good point and i think
that uh i was probably sloppy when i was
giving the discussion even though i you
know for purposes of explanation
distinguished between a kind of person
called an intellectual
and a kind of person called an activist
it's much more accurate as you're
getting at to say that there are
roles in which any one person sometimes
plays the role of an intellectual trying
to figure out the truth and sometimes
plays the role of an activist and
there's probably zero people
who are 100 one or the other right
there's always a little bit of both um
so how do you balance that is basically
what you're saying you know where would
you set the boundary in between living
you know and different people are going
to do it differently i think that you
know my i'm
personally most comfortable um being
much more intellectual than an activist
but i do think that it's important to
make the world a better place if we can
i just don't feel comfortable with doing
that in ways that would be
anti-intellectual that would involve
you know what i said was
if your
goal is primarily to change the world
then i can absolutely see circumstances
in which doing something other than
telling the truth would be involved but
if your goal is a little bit to change
the world and a lot to tell the truth
then i don't see why you should ever not
tell the truth you know do your best to
change the world in ways that are
compatible with telling the truth that's
what i would try to do
kyle morrow says
why isn't gravity or the gravitational
field constantly decohering quantum
systems and getting rid of their
wave-like natures seems like even a
single particle would be constantly
updating space-time with its position
and energy well this is a subtle
question actually and i don't think that
the answer is completely understood but
let me just add a little bit of a true
fact that might help you see what's
going on you know think about the sun
okay that's a big quantum particle it's
a very big quantum particle in the
approximation we are ignoring the
internal degrees of freedom of the sun
and it has a gravitational field um but
the gravitational field sort of exists
as part of it the gravitational field
isn't changing there's just the sun and
the gravitational field of the sun it's
like kind of one system right so the sun
isn't in the approximation where the sun
is just sitting there alone in the
universe
there's no dynamics
it has a gravitational field pull stop
that's all there's going on decoherence
is of necessity a dynamical process
decoherence is the transition from two
systems being unentangled to two systems
becoming entangled or one of those
systems is the environment right so the
gravitational field of a single object
isn't the environment an environment you
should think of as a lot of propagating
degrees of freedom like a lot of photons
or a lot of atoms or something like that
it's not the field that is attached to
some object so it's not the
gravitational field per se that would be
doing the deco hearing but you could
imagine gravitons doing the decoy
hearing right like if you moved the sun
and it gave off some gravitons those
could sort of scatter into the
environment and if they then interacted
with other things in the universe then
you could decohere but you need a lot of
that right i mean gravity is very very
weak so it becomes a quantitative
question you actually have to calculate
how quickly it happens that turns out to
be hard to do which is why like i said
it turns out to be a subtle question
okay lester sue says i think you've said
before
that all good bayesians should update
their priors in the same way based on
objective new facts but if a bayesian
starts out with their subjective priors
surely those priors would and should
also inform how they assess new facts
and therefore how that will update those
priors or is there an objective standard
to how you assess new facts as a
bayesian independent of your priors
um so i'm not quite sure that i'm
interpreting the question correctly but
i'm going to interpret it in a way that
i think is a charitable way in the sense
that i'm going to interpret the way that
i agree this is a really good issue to
worry about namely
none of us is perfect bayesians in fact
even the thought experiment of bayesian
reasoning is just something that does
not map on to the how the real world
works okay
because what what bayesian reasoning
says is you say you have your priors for
various different propositions and those
are in some sense subjective okay
different people are allowed to start
with different priors they think that
some things are more likely some things
are less likely
but you're not allowed to pick your own
likelihood so the likelihood is the
theoretical prediction given the
different proposition you want to
believe in what is the probability of
getting certain data coming in certain
new information
and we pretend that those likelihoods
are completely objective but in practice
they're not because often the
propositions we're trying to
um
judge in some way
are not perfectly well defined okay so
previously we were talking about the
likelihood of life existing in the
universe under theism or atheism so i'm
happy to say that the probability of
life existing under theism is very very
large
it would be what point will be the point
of having god around to be if god didn't
you know create life somewhere
but i don't know what the number is i
don't think that the the phrase theism
attaches to any sufficiently
well-defined theory to let me predict
what this
purportedly objective likelihood
function is right so that's one real
world
shortcoming of the bayesian paradigm and
the other is what i think you're getting
at lester which is that
um well there's two there's two things
but but both of them have to do with the
way that we take in new data or new
information
one is when we get some new information
what is the credibility that we give to
that information maybe our brains are
misleading us or maybe we're just being
lied to or whatever and the same amount
of information
might be judged to have different
amounts of credibility by two different
people so in principle
that is something to worry about but
it's something that bayesian reasoning
is perfectly adapted to taking care of
you you sort of take that into account
when you define what is your proposition
what is your likelihood you know what is
the data and all that stuff right you
know the all of these have different
probabilities associated with them and
they all get um massaged in to the final
answer in the correct way
an even more interesting issue to me is
that we don't take in the same
information right and this again goes
back to the question that we were
talking about before with theism versus
atheism because
if the only thing you looked at was the
fact that there's life in the universe
you might get one answer but then if you
also look at the fact that
there are many other galaxies with many
other stars the universe is big and it's
old and it's a mess etc etc then you
might get a very different picture so
increasingly and this isn't directly
related to your question but it's just
something i've been thinking about
myself
i i'm impressed
impressed might not be the word i care a
lot about the fact that
we are computationally bounded as
stephen wolfram said it although i was
thinking about it for other reasons with
other words attached to it but we're
finite right we don't take in all of the
data um in zainab two fetch keys words
from several podcasts ago
attention is the
precious
quantity
um
that we are talking about now not
information there's too much information
out there what do you pay attention to
and since we are tiny finite people we
need to choose what to pay attention to
and so even two people who agree on all
of the priors and agree on all the
likelihoods might choose to pay
attention to different inputs and
therefore get different data that they
use to update their bayesian
credences
and so
this is this is not to say that bayesian
reasoning is wrong in any way it's not
wrong uh it's an idealization of what
really happens in the real world and so
i think that there's probably and maybe
it's already been done i don't know i'm
not an expert in these things but
there's probably a lot of work to be
done or that has been done on
uh bounded rationality right i think
that's a technical term for it the fact
that we are not perfect either in
reasoning or information gathering and
therefore what's the best you can do
under those circumstances uh there's
probably been a lot written on that that
i don't know about so maybe we should
have someone on the podcast talk about
it
fabian rosedalen says
regarding your work in very fundamental
questions of the universe have you ever
had to deal with any existential anxiety
or pain or anything like that do you
have any thoughts about how quantum
physics could influence these matters
either positively or negatively uh so no
and no are the short answers here
you know i think i've said this before
when i was a kid when i like first
started thinking about cosmology and
things like that there was a little bit
of anxiety involved and it was
specifically
with the question of you know like what
if i hadn't existed
unbeknownst to my young self i was
thinking in i was doing modal reasoning
i was thinking about the space of all
possible worlds and there's there are
possible worlds in which i didn't exist
or there are possible worlds in which
the universe doesn't exist or though
should we call that a world i'm not sure
but anyway um that always seemed to be
like the end point of where i could
sensibly reason about things and that
made me nervous or
maybe even anxious
uh but then yeah so
i think that now when i'm thinking about
those questions
i'm just not sure that you know i've
talked before i did a whole podcast solo
episode about why is there something
rather than nothing
and the answer that i advocated there is
that's not a question to which we have
any right to think that there's an
answer
we can formulate questions in what
appears to be a grammatically legitimate
way why is x true right and very often
we can get answers to those questions
but it turns out that those answers are
embedded in a context right why is
my car out of gas well because i was
going to put gas in it yesterday but i
forgot or why is my car out of battery
since i have an electric car
but these are all in that context and
the question why does the universe exist
doesn't have a kind of context in which
there would be a sensible answer so it's
not the answer is we don't know
or uh
the question is outside our powers to
address or anything like that it's just
that it's not a good question it's not
an answerable question it's not a
question that has an answer so
that tends to be more my attitude these
days with the kinds of questions that
would lead to existential anxiety and
quantum mechanics has nothing to do with
it as far as i can tell i'm not really
sure why it would especially for someone
like myself who
is a thorough going physicalist about
quantum mechanics there's this quantum
state and obeys an equation i'm not sure
why that would change my existential
anxiety over classical mechanics in any
way
ratboy.exec
uh probably also not their real name
says
i recently listened to your talk with
philip gough on pan psychism and was
absolutely enthralled one thing that
struck me was the discussion on
intrinsic properties those that don't
govern observable behavior and aren't
captured by mathematics it reminded me
of your discussion with max tegmark who
seem to argue there's no such thing to
the extent that the universe is nothing
more than an abstract mathematical
structure and even further that this
universe is not uniquely real among
mathematical structures my question is
this if your position is that there are
no intrinsic properties what in your
view distinguishes the world from the
abstract mathematical structure
described by tegmark and if in contrast
to techmark's view this universe
possesses a unique property called
existence would that qualify as a sort
of intrinsic property that we get to be
privy to by virtue of our being internal
to the structure so
i think that
it's hard to give a completely
satisfactory answer to this without a
rigorous definition of the phrase
intrinsic property okay it's one of
those things where we think we know what
the word intrinsic means we think we
know what a property is and therefore we
think we know what the phrase means but
it gets a little bit slipperier upon
further examination um so
you know
in mathematics in set theory
there is a definition of property
and it's a little deflationary it's just
a subset
right you have a set of many many things
and you want to talk about a property
that some things have and some don't you
just
enumerate the ones that have the
property and so the property is simply
uh equivalent isomorphic to the subset
that's what a property is in in set
theory so i could take that attitude
about properties of physical things too
i could say you know properties are just
a way of saying like if i say the
the property of moving at the speed of
light is just the set of all things in
the universe moving at the speed of
light right and then it gets a little
bit tricky to do that carefully but
something like that could happen so now
you're adding the adjective intrinsic to
property i don't know what that means i
don't know what that is supposed to mean
especially if you're saying that it's an
intrinsic property that doesn't change
its observable behavior in any way
i mean i know what properties are i know
what electric charge is i know what mass
is and the reason why i know what they
are is because they play a role
dynamically they appear in the equations
of motion that predict what's going to
happen to this physical system if you
say well i have another kind of property
that's really important but it has no
effect whatsoever on what happens
i'm not really moved by that right um
now so you're trying to pick out the
specific example of existence as a
property and i'm not sure what that
means exactly so i am and this might be
my failings i'm not i'm not trying to
make fun of you i'm making fun of myself
here i'm i'm i'm opening up to uh things
that i haven't thought about very deeply
so i could be completely wrong but i'm
going to give you my initial impression
i do think that there's something called
the universe my phrase from my own point
of view about this is reality realism
what do i think is real reality
what is that well i don't know but we're
trying to figure that out that's what
science is trying to do what we try to
do is model reality and when we model
reality we do so usually with a
mathematical formal system of some sort
and so i'm not a tegmarkian in the sense
that i think all different mathematical
systems exist for reasons that i tried
to make clear during that podcast i
think that the real world exists and
it's described by some mathematics and
not others okay
so
does is
could you think about that as saying
well consider the space of all possible
worlds and point to one and say this is
special because that's the property
called existence
sure i think so i think that's a
possible thing to do but i don't think
it's a necessary thing to do i could
just say the real world exists and i
could stop i don't need to compare it to
all the other non-existent worlds so
it's a very useful that that makes me
not a modal realist modal realism long
before max tegmark
was this idea of david lewis's that all
the alternative possible worlds exist in
some real sense and all we try to do is
figure out which one we're in okay
i think that's a very good reasoning
strategy
i think it's very uh you know when we're
asking ourselves what are the correct
laws of physics uh that is exactly
equivalent to saying
consider all the possible worlds with
different laws of physics which one are
we in but i don't think that anything is
is added by saying that the other worlds
really exist
or so i think that our world exists and
that is different but it's not a
property that our world has it's just
the world that there's nothing extra to
it
now if you don't understand the many
worlds of quantum mechanics very well
you might think that this is
hypocritical because i do think that the
other worlds exist in quantum mechanics
but that's because they are causally
connected to our world they were part of
our world before and they split off and
there's an equation that describes that
it's not simply a posit that says
imagine they're all there they're a
dynamical prediction of the schrodinger
equation
i hope that was an answer to your
question i'm not sure but i did my best
okay
ken wolfe says back in the day we were
all taught that there were just three
types of chemical bonds covalent ionic
and metallic
i recently read an article by philip
ball about how new research suggests
there might be new types of chemical
bonds such as ones that blur the line
between covalent and metallic this got
me to wondering whether any new
developments in quantum electrodynamics
could possibly give us new insight into
how chemical bonds might work do you
think this is possible
a shorter version of the question could
changes in the standard model change our
understanding of how chemical bonds work
or is that pretty much locked in by now
i think that's pretty much locked in by
now this is part and parcel of the idea
that the laws of uh physics underlying
our everyday lives are completely
understood right the core theory is is
what we have um and roughly speaking you
know it's completely possible that we
will learn more about chemical bonds
than we know now but the laws of physics
that give rise to chemical bonds the
fundamental equations of quantum
electrodynamics and the standard model
those are there they're not changing and
the reason why we know is because we can
characterize what kinds of possible
changes there are and we can look for
them we can do the experiments to see
whether they're there and so far they're
not
and we can we've pushed any possible
modification of the standard model out
to regimes where
it very well could be there but it would
have no effect whatsoever on chemistry
or anything like that um
think about you know the podcast i
recently did on the muons right on
different
possible
we don't know but possible new physics
signatures of how muons decay and
interact and their magnetic moments
these are so incredibly tiny we're not
even sure they're there
but they have zero effect on chemistry
or anything like that and and that's the
only thing that we have seen that could
possibly be
or is let's say it's the most reasonable
most likely deviation from the standard
model we've yet seen so that is my
opinion about that
could be wrong like the thing about
saying things like this is one could
always be wrong but you know that one
has to do what the best one can do about
assigning credences to different
possibilities my credence that new
fundamental physics is going to change
chemistry is very very very tiny indeed
ryan morrison says i'm not an expert in
psychology but i think maslow's
hierarchy of needs and the idea that we
can make progress as humans
is pretty attractive do you ever think
about the idea of transcending the self
or have you moved away from that kind of
thinking do you think it's possible to
be totally fulfilled
well luckily ryan i did a whole podcast
on that with scott barry kaufman and
scott is a psychologist who actually is
a huge fan of maslow and he has updated
maslow's hierarchy of needs uh in a way
that i think is really
uh much better you know i i get what you
mean the hierarchy of needs is an
attractive notion but there's something
that is missing about it and so what
scott points out is number one maslow
never drew the pyramid you know the
famous pyramid picture uh that was done
by later commentators and the pyramid as
a metaphor is a little bit misleading
because it's a little too solid right it
makes you think that there really is you
know a
structure that we're climbing to get to
transcendence at the top of it whereas
the world
reality in our lives is much more
dynamic and so scott is trying is
arguing for replacing the pyramid
metaphor with a sailboat metaphor which
i like i mean i basically am and totally
a fan of this way of thinking
so no i don't think it's possible to be
totally fulfilled i think that's a
misunderstanding of what it means to be
alive and human
to be alive and human is to be a process
to be changing the changes might be
under the surface or they might be very
obvious but it's completely wrong in my
view to imagine that there is one state
that we just need to get into and then
our work is done i think that's the
opposite of how we should think about
living our lives
casey mahone says i've been thinking a
lot about your notion of emergent space
time in my mind it raises a similar
issue as the hard problem of
consciousness in both cases it seems
completely unclear to me how something
of a totally different kind can arise
simply through emergence
well
i'm sorry that it seems unclear but it
happens all the time i mean that is one
of the great things about emergence one
of the things that you learn about
emergence is
um
the rules of the emergent theory can
have no obvious connection to the rules
of the underlying theory there will be a
non-obvious connection there might be
some subtle connection
and will be there because they have to
be ultimately compatible but the as we
say the ontology the different kinds of
stuff you have in the emerging theory
can be totally different the most
obvious and well
thought about example is quantum
mechanics and classical mechanics in
quantum mechanics the stuff
is a wave function a vector in hilbert
space that's what you start with and
what you see at the end
are particles of classical mechanics
right particles and fields living in
space-time a completely different kind
of thing and forget about emergent
space-time okay just quantum mechanics
just good old quantum mechanics see the
hydrogen atom right
the hydrogen atom the sort of picture
that we draw the rutherford atom with
little dots in the middle to represent
the nucleus and little dots orbiting to
represent the electrons that gets us a
certain place but it's not the
underlying quantum reality once you get
to the solar system
same thing right the solar system is
very well represented as a big sun with
rocks planets orbiting around it but the
real thing is an underlying quantum wave
function emergence just does that all
the time the question is is there a map
from the underlying microscopic states
to the emergent macroscopic states and
the map can relate two very very
different theories
rob griber says
this month i wanted to ask a question
from my seven-year-old daughter lyanna
so this is a hint to other future ama
askers like i'm a sucker for these kinds
of questions so please don't lie but if
you really want a question answered it
does increase your chances if the
question comes from your seven-year-old
daughter
the question is professional
professor carol
if you were standing on the photon
sphere of a black hole and you looked
forward you would see the back of your
head is that right what would happen if
you looked up what would you see and
what would uh you see around you to the
left and the right
so i want to be a little bit careful
here because there's the real world and
there's sort of physics idealized play
land okay so there is in the world of
black hole something called the photon
sphere this is the
region around the black hole a little
bit outside the event horizon where a
photon
could travel exactly roughly speaking
exactly parallel to the event horizon at
a constant distance above it okay so a
photon could just go in a circle right
um and you call that the photon sphere
it's outside the event horizon so it's
not the region from which you can't
escape if you were on the photon sphere
and fire your rocket engine you could
escape okay but if you were just there
and you were not a photon you could send
out a photon in exactly the right
direction and it would go around and you
would indeed see the back of your head
that's the story we tell anyway in the
real world there's an extra fact that
becomes very important which is that
these orbits of photons on the photon
sphere are not stable
if you deviate the direction in which
the photon is pointing by any tiny bit
at all the photon will either fall into
the black hole or zoom off to infinity
so in the real world there's going to be
almost no photons on the photon sphere
almost all of them that might have come
close will either fall into the black
hole or zoom off to infinity so you
probably won't see anything special at
the photon sphere in the real world um
but let's go you know go along with the
thought experiment what happened if you
looked up or left or right well
i'm not exactly sure what direction
you're pointing in here of course out in
outer space there's no such thing as up
down left to right right all the
directions are created equal so
basically if you're next to the black
hole there's only two options you're
either looking
well i guess there's three options
you're looking toward the black hole
away from the black hole or
perpendicular to the black hole right
and if you're looking along the photon
sphere you're looking perpendicular to
the black hole so it doesn't matter
whether you look straight or up or
backward in any of those directions
you're looking perpendicular to the
black hole and you would see the black
of your head the back of your head if
you look toward the black hole you see
nothing it's black roughly speaking you
could see something that was in the
process of just falling into it that's
very possible but the black hole itself
is just black if you look the other way
you see the real world the outside world
you see all the stars and your your
friends back in the spaceship who are
thinking of themselves what are they
doing messing around near the photon
sphere they're going to be in trouble um
but otherwise it's perfectly normal so
in fact to the to a large extent it is
just perfectly normal don't think of the
photon sphere as a very dramatic place
that you would notice if you were
visiting the vicinity of a black hole
jesse rimler says music emerges from the
naturally occurring overtone series
which is the same everywhere in the
universe the scales and chords we build
out of this vary from culture to culture
as a thought experiment i tried to
imagine a fundamentally different kind
of musical harmony beyond cultural or
timbral differences am i right to
conclude that it would have to be a
universe with a different kind of math
since the octave and the overtone series
are based on mathematical relationships
well
i think the real answer that i have to
give here is i don't even know what it
would mean
to talk about a universe with a
different kind of math i can imagine
talking about a universe with a
different kind of physics right
different laws of physics but math is
math like math goes back and forth
between universes uh the pythagoras's
theorem follows from euclidean geometry
no matter what universe you're in and
likewise the fact that uh 440 divided by
2 is 220 is going to be true in every
universe right so i don't think it's a
matter of different kinds of math there
could be different kinds of laws of
physics
but then you know there might not be
sound or something like that so i'm not
sure what we're talking about so i don't
think looking at different kinds of math
is the right way to go here i think that
um looking at different relationships
within the known laws of math between
different frequencies and different
combinations of frequencies might be the
way to go i mean an obvious way to go
is to go beyond the idea of discrete
individual
frequencies right like it's usually just
to keep our lives simple
we build instruments that mostly play
one note at a time it's not always true
of course you can think of counter
examples to that but typically a note on
an instrument is a note that is centered
in its frequency in its spectral
resolution around a single frequency and
you know going beyond that to more
complicated spectra of sounds coming out
of a system might be an interesting way
to go i don't know i'm just making
things up
michael edelman says in the last ama you
dismissed the idea of nations having
intelligence or consciousness
likening it to anthropomorphizing given
that consciousness appears to be an
emergent property of sufficiently large
number networks of neurons why shouldn't
we also see conscious states arise from
networks of more complex organisms like
humans and animals george dyson
suggested this in his darwin among the
machines 24 years ago drawing parallels
to hobbes's leviathan so i forget what i
said last month and the last day of may
but uh in principle sure i mean in
principle you could have giant
consciousnesses made out of tinier
pieces that played the role of neurons
or something like that but the fact that
it is possible in principle doesn't mean
it actually happens in practice in the
current world
uh you know i think that the
consciousness that we have in our human
brains is
pretty dependent on special properties
of our particular human brains there's
other ways i'm very sure that you could
have consciousness but it's not just
going to
pop into existence without any effort
right you know we are the result of
billions of years of evolution
[Music]
most of those billions of years we were
single-celled organisms but still there
were selection pressures that were
shaping what we have in our brains and
in our nervous systems and in our
biology to compete in certain
environments and to reproduce and so
forth and the ultimate result of that is
uh the capacity that we have in our
brains to do information processing in a
very coherent way right in a way that
gives us a sense of self a sense of i
whereas a nation is a bunch of people
that is much more loosely organized than
that with no special structure no
special um
rules of engagement and ways that
different connections are drawn and
different substructures like the brain
has and so forth so it would be
astonishing to me if
real societies were sufficiently similar
to human brains that we would call them
conscious organisms and indeed i don't
think that's how it is you know when you
actually want to convince a nation to do
something
it's much more useful to convince the
boss of that nation to do something than
try to convince the nation as a whole
one of the aspects of why nations are
very different than brains is that
brains don't have a president or a king
or an emperor none of their neurons is
the king neuron yeah that's just not how
it works so
yeah in principle the laws of physics do
not prevent nations from being conscious
but in practice i think it's kind of a
different thing
peter b says one of your earlier guest
lenders huskind
has argued that inflation must create
infinite open universes with negative
curvature yet you have mentioned that we
live in a deceiter space with positive
curvature so i'm confused are we living
on a giant pringle chip or a giant
balloon
well so
i don't know this is possibly my fault
but um it depends you have to
distinguish between the curvature of
space and the curvature of space-time
okay that's one thing the other thing is
that what lenny is saying about the
negative curvature we don't know if
that's true or not okay so the
difference between spatial curvature and
space-time curvature is when we have
cosmology
in cosmology there is a special
situation which is not necessarily true
in other um
aspects in other situations let's say in
general relativity where
spatial slices are homogeneous and
isotropic okay there's a special way of
slicing space time into space plus time
so the spatial sections are more or less
the same everywhere on large scales so
unlike uh just an empty flat spacetime
minkowski space in cosmology there is a
best way of slicing space time into
space plus time so then given that we
can talk about the curvature of space as
well as the curvature of space-time
the curvature of space
is pretty close to zero we've measured
it we've not measured any overall
deviation from zero so it could be
very very small but positive or it could
be very very small but negative or it
could be zero
to any any process any practical
precision so what lenny is pointing out
is that
in his favorite version of eternal
inflation
where there is bubble nucleation
uh where a little bubble of true vacuum
or at least lower energy vacuum comes
into existence inside a high energy
false vacuum state you will very
naturally get spatial slices that are
negative curvature
now the spatial slices can be negative
curvature whether or not
space
is positively or negatively curved and
you know there as we said before there's
different kinds of curvature that
space-time can have there's ritchie
scalar rigid curvature and vile
curvature etc so when you even say
positive and negative you're already
simplifying things an enormous amount
but the point is that our universe is
headed toward
uh being empty other than for a positive
cosmological constant right that's the
future of our universe there'll be
nothing left but the positive
cosmological constant and that will be a
deceiter geometry overall
a space time with a positive curvature
that's completely compatible with the
surfaces of constant energy in cosmology
being negative curvature there's a
difference between the curvature of the
overall space time and how you slice it
into space plus time so the two are
actually compatible it's also possible
that there are other ways of doing
eternal inflation like what jennifer
chen and i looked at years ago where you
have baby new baby universes being
created
that nucleate as spherical bubbles off
of the parent space-time in which case
the spatial sections would also be
positive curvature so we don't know
whether space is positively curved
negatively curved or zero we do have
good empirical evidence that space time
is headed toward a positive curvature
state
so mark zug says regarding photons
interfering with themselves what is
wrong with the idea that electromagnetic
energy must travel as waves but only be
detected as particles uh nothing nothing
wrong with that idea that's perfectly
sensible it's it's an incomplete idea
because it's kind of mixing
classical language with quantum
mechanical language
classically uh the electromagnetic field
is a wave right it's an electromagnetic
wave and then if you add a little bit of
quantum mechanics in you say that when
you detect the electromagnetic wave you
detect discrete packets of energy aka
particles now if you're a little bit
more careful if you're going fully
quantum mechanical then that original
electromagnetic wave was itself quantum
mechanical it was the quantum
field wave okay and that's a little bit
more complicated but still it was a wave
so yeah i think that as a rule of thumb
saying that em waves travel as waves but
detected as particles is more or less on
the right track
mark matthews says could quarks in a
proton run into their virtual antiquark
counterpart
and exchange places with a virtual quark
mediated by a gluon resulting in a
virtual quark to replace the original
quark so okay there's a bunch of things
going on there i'm not quite sure what
the picture is but the reason why i
wanted to answer this question was
just to talk a little bit about
this thing that we always say that
quarks and neutrons for that matter that
protons and neutrons for that matter
have three quarks in them uh in the case
of a proton two ups and a down in the
case of a neutron two downs and an up
it's not really like that okay anyone
who's taken quantum field theory who
thinks very carefully about particle
physics knows better this is a very
sloppy way of talking about protons and
neutrons the reality is that protons and
neutrons inside are a bubbling c
of actually that's not even the reality
a slightly better metaphor is that
inside protons and neutrons there's a
bubbling sea of quarks and antiquarks
and gluons okay
um
they're virtual particles and it's not
just like the occasional virtual
particle it's mostly virtual particles
there's a a whole bunch of things going
on now the reason why i say that's not
exactly right is that even that is
speaking too classically and using a
particle-like language what's really
going on are there quantum fields
that are not separable into individual
particles that's that's the truth of it
usually you don't want the truth you
usually want the picture and so
the vivid picture is a roiling sea of
particles popping into and out of
existence the reason why that's not a
great picture is that it gives you the
idea
that inside the proton or neutron things
are changing over time right things are
popping out of existence and they're not
the inside of a proton neutron is static
nothing is happening inside there if you
were to observe it you would see
different things at different times but
that's because of the disturbance that
you're putting on it by observing it
anyway
if you want to speak this particle
language at all
it is much more accurate to think of it
as a whole bunch of quarks and
antiquarks and gluons always interacting
and popping out of existence and
creating and annihilating and so forth
and what
practice particle physicists will do is
talk about the valence quarks inside a
proton or neutron what they mean by that
is
when you typically say there is there
are two ups and a down in a proton
what you mean is if you count up all of
the quarks and all of the anti-quarks
and all of the gluons
on average uh sorry not not on average
there will be lots of quarks and
anti-quarks but there will always be
precisely more three more quarks than
anti-quarks inside the proton okay
that's the point and the reason why you
know it's precisely three is because
there's a baryon number that is uh one
third per quark and the total for the
proton is equal to one and that's true
okay there is one third baryon number
per quark
uh and the total has to equal three so
the total has to equal one my brain is
not really working today man this i'm
gonna get to harder math in a second so
i better get her in better increase my
mathematical skills here one-third times
three equals one there we go
so there's an excess of three quarks
over anti-quarks in a proton or a
neutron and there's in fact an excess of
two up quarks and one down quark over
their antiparticles but
there's a tremendous number of quarks
and antiquarks popping out existence all
the time if you want to use that virtual
particle metaphor at all that's the best
i can do without going into the
equations
michael ayling says can you suggest one
or two books that give an overview of
the philosophy of science and highlight
some of the current issues those in the
field are tackling
so sadly my answer here is no i cannot
suggest those books but let me explain
why um
there are two very different kinds of
things related but different kinds of
things that get labeled as philosophy of
science
one kind of thing is the philosophy of
how science works
so if you think about thomas [ __ ] fire
rob and popper right the famous names in
the philosophy of science they're
thinking about how we invent theories
how we decide what theories are true how
theories change over time and it it goes
right into the sociology of science
right different research practices
different communities how they talk to
each other that is something called
philosophy of science but then there's
something that is usually called
philosophy of physics or philosophy of
biology or philosophy of mathematics
okay like things that you might say are
part of philosophy of science but are in
fact not interested in how theories are
chosen but they're interested in how the
world works
so a philosopher of physics is
interested in the foundations of quantum
mechanics or the foundations of
space-time philosophers of biology are
interested in how evolution works and
whether or not there's selection
pressures at different levels or things
like that all that stuff okay so that
kind of philosophy of science is more
continuous with science than with the
sociology of science and it's that kind
of philosophy of science that is sort of
the philosophical side of science that
is much more what i personally am
interested in but
if you were to buy a book on the
philosophy of science if reported to be
an overview
i think that most of it would be about
the former kind it would mostly be about
theory choice and how research programs
work and and stuff like that and that's
interesting and important stuff but i'm
not an expert in it so i'm not i don't
really have any good recommendations
there whereas if you wanted to buy a
book in the other stuff
uh it's probably a different book for
philosophy of physics versus philosophy
of biology versus philosophy of
mathematics or something like that um i
can i could think of books off the top
of my head in all those areas although
i'm not familiar enough with the entire
set of books to say that it's the best
there's a set of books by tim maudlin
that are you know introductions to
philosophies of physics
uh there's a new book by david wallace a
very short introduction to the
philosophy of physics which i haven't
seen but i'm sure is is very good
there's a book by alex rosenberg
previous mindscape guest on the
philosophy of biology that is that is
very good an intro book um and
philosophy of math i have a few books
and i can't remember honestly who wrote
them but uh you could look i haven't
read any of them i just owned them i've
glanced through them for particular
reasons i need to know one fact about
girdle's theorem or or whatever
uh but that's that's my overview of the
whole state of the field so i can't
really offer one or two books that
answer the question
connor scott says if a neutron star is
propped up by the pali exclusion
principle and if the palsy exclusion
principle
only forbids fermions from being in the
same quantum state then wouldn't it be
the natural assumption in the case of a
neutron star gaining mass and collapsing
into a black hole to say that the
simplest ground state of the fermions is
no longer to distinguish their quantum
states by position by some other factor
so
there's a simple answer but behind it
there's a more complicated issue here
the simple answer is we know
what the degrees of freedom are that
fermions can have at least the fermions
we know about like protons and neutrons
or the quarks that make them up okay so
there aren't new factors that can
distinguish between them otherwise there
wouldn't be neutron stars because you
could just pack different particles with
different values of those degrees of
freedom as densely as you want um so
it's an interesting fact it goes into
you know i i wrote about this we talked
about pan psychism or we didn't talk
about psychism but i've been thinking
about we talk about consciousness
i
i remember we talked about philip gough
that's what it was someone mentioned pan
psychism and philip gough so philip uh
is um having a he's editing a collection
of essays in response to his book called
galileo's error and uh
essays from different people from very
different perspectives and i was one of
the people he asked to write an essay so
i did that and those of you who follow
me on twitter might have seen it called
consciousness and the laws of physics
and of course there's a whole bunch of
things that have been written about
consciousness and laws of physics and my
thing is different because i'm really
not talking about consciousness at all
in the same spirit as my book the big
picture i'm just trying to make the
argument that whatever consciousness is
it's probably not a good idea to try to
explain it by changing the laws of
physics okay and to this does get back
to the police solution principle just
just trust me
the connection is that
one way that you might imagine to be
pan-psychists
one way and only one way not the only
way but one way to imagine being
pan-cyclist is to imagine there is a new
degree of freedom
for material particles like electrons
and quarks namely a mental degree of
freedom
there might be two mental states just to
keep things simple maybe there's you
know a million mental states but there
might be two different mental states
that an electron could be in maybe happy
or sad but the point is that if that new
mental degree of freedom acted like an
ordinary physical degree of freedom like
spin for example we would have detected
it a long time ago
the number of degrees of freedom that
elementary particles have
comes into
calculations like the probability the
two electrons scatter off of each other
or something like that okay so anyway
we know how many degrees of freedom
particles have there aren't any new ones
and that's true for new possible mental
degrees of freedom but it's also true
for possible new physical degrees of
freedom now what is possible is that the
neutrons in a neutron star can under
great pressure convert into even heavier
particles
the whole reason why when a white dwarf
collapses the electrons and protons
convert into neutrons is that the
neutron is heavier than an electron and
therefore you can squeeze them more
tightly into each other so probably what
happens along the way of a collapse of a
neutron star is that
neutrons sort of become energetic enough
they can convert into even heavier
particles and be squeezed more closely
but
as far as we know whatever they convert
into it's not a stable configuration
that would stop them from collapsing all
the way into a black hole as far as we
know chris shipton says is there a is
there a relationship between the halting
problem and the traveling salesman
problem
um
i mean roughly speaking no you know i'm
not a super expert at this stuff so of
course there are some relationships that
they are both
problems right in computational uh
complexity theory in some sense but the
traveling salesman problem is hard
it takes a lot of steps to figure out
what is the best route between you know
all these different cities but the
halting problem is literally unsolvable
okay that there's a difference between
unsolvable and hard hard means it takes
a lot of steps the halting problem is it
literally can't be solved there's
literally no way of knowing just by
looking at a computer program whether it
is guaranteed to halt or not
other than running it and seeing if it
halts but there you can only show that
it does halt in a certain period of time
you can't show that it doesn't like if
you run it for an hour you're not and it
doesn't halt you're not sure whether it
would run for a year or run forever okay
so that's a literally unsolvable problem
which is very different than the
traveling salesman
john dick says given an everettian
perspective
what would be the consequence if our
universe the vacuum happened to be in a
meta-stable state with a decay time of
only a million years could we tell
um you know the everyday perspective
doesn't change anything in questions
like this it's the same perspective it's
the same quantum mechanical prediction
the prediction is that if we're in a
meta-stable vacuum there's a probability
per unit time in per unit spatial volume
that a lower energy vacuum tunnels into
existence so if the decay time for that
happening is a million years you need to
tell me per what volume also but but i
get what you mean like let's say per the
volume of our observable universe okay
well our observable universe is much
more than a million years old so it
would have been overwhelmingly likely
that we would have already decayed now
there is an anthropic cutoff right i
mean there's an entropic consideration
maybe it is the case that uh
if
the new vacuum nucleates and takes over
our old space the laws of physics within
the new vacuum do not allow for the
existence of life
and therefore
um
there's one branch of the wave function
where these uh decays haven't happened
yet and that's the only place we can
live
i can buy that uh but then we would you
know within a million years we would
probably die that would be the
prediction of that and there'd be some
other branch of the wave function where
we hadn't died yet et cetera et cetera
so i think that's a little fishy i'm not
a fan of those kinds of anthropic
arguments because i don't know what uh
the laws of physics are going to be in
the new universe etc etc and um
it's just much easier in the space of
all my credences to imagine that the
lifetime of our universe is really
really long billions of years and
therefore was just likely we haven't
seen it yet that's my guess
anders says the kalam cosmological
argument for god is regularly trotted
out everything that begins to exist has
a cause the universe began to exist
therefore the universe has a cause and
with a little hand waving you get to god
this seems like something a cosmologist
would have something to say about is
there a reason why you don't accept it
so
yes for some of you you'll know that i
did a debate with william lane craig
about this very issue because this is
william lane craig's favorite proof for
the existence of god and the short
version to my response is
we don't know whether the universe began
to exist or not maybe it did maybe it
didn't that's just an open question
but we do know that the first premise
everything that begins to exist has a
cause is just false that's just not the
right way to talk about fundamental
physics kinds of questions uh there's
two options that you have one is if
you're in the emergent higher level
world of me and you and tables and
chairs and cups of coffee and things
like that then there is a very natural
language of cause and effect and that
language of cause and effect is very
dependent on entropy in the arrow of
time okay and so we're not describing
the world at the microphysical level
we're not laplace's demon we have
incomplete information about the world
we coarse grain the world and in that
higher level coarse grain description
causes and effects are very very
important the other option but but
obviously it doesn't tell us anything
about the beginning of the universe
because that is not described by that
coarse grained higher level description
the other option is that we give
a description in the microphysical
language the fundamental laws of physics
okay but as far as we currently
understand the fundamental laws of
physics they don't have cause and effect
in them as concepts
instead they have differential equations
and they say the universe whatever
mathematical structure you are using to
describe it like a wave function or
something like that obeys this equation
that's the laws of physics there's not
an extra law that says that things have
causes okay the only law is here's the
stuff it obeys this equation that is our
current paradigm for doing the laws of
physics and so the
point is you don't say everything that
begins to exist has a cause you say
everything obeys the laws of physics
and once you say it that way you're not
going to get to god existing right you
just say the universe obeys the laws of
physics the universe may or may not have
begun to exist
and there's no therefore god exists
right that's just not a possible
conclusion
siddhartha says
can any seemingly non-deterministic
universe be truly random at the
fundamental level even if entities
inside the universe cannot tell doesn't
the universe itself somehow need to pick
one or all in many worlds a possibility
following some deterministic process so
i think siddhartha you're just sort of
insisting that you don't believe that
things can be non-deterministic i don't
know what to tell you uh i don't think
we have the right to make those
insistences you know it's a it's a nice
feature of the laws of physics and our
current best understanding that they are
deterministic but if we learn more
tomorrow and learn that they weren't
then we would have to accept that uh i
see no reason whatsoever
to say a priori that i can't imagine
non-deterministic laws of physics i mean
that's just a failure of your
imagination i can imagine
non-deterministic laws of physics no
problem
i don't know what you mean by imagine
here but i can certainly write down
possible worlds that obey
non-deterministic laws and we could live
in those one of those that's just an
empirical question i don't know what
else to say
corby zeesman asks a priority question
my question ties into the quantum
suicide type thought experiment but is
related to blockchain security
basically your cryptocurrency money is
protected by a 256-bit private key
nearly impossible to guess but one could
use a quantum random number generator or
the universe splitter app to generate
265 one bit quantum results this means
you would have two to the power 256
timelines in superposition where each
version of you tries a unique 256 bit
permutation this exercises all possible
cryptocurrency private keys meaning
there is a timeline where you
successfully guessed every single user's
private key and then it goes on a little
bit further than that but
i can answer the question here because
you know this is an answer that i give
to many similar questions this is a
particular version of this question
where it's been dressed up with
cryptocurrency or blockchain or whatever
but it's a version of the following
question there is a set of things which
in
traditional ways of thinking about
quantum mechanics are just stochastic
right or just unpredictable and in many
worlds you predict with 100 probability
there is a world in which one answer
comes true in a world in which another
answer comes true and then some attempt
is made to leverage that into some
important difference and i'm going to
say again and again there is no
important difference between those cases
by important i mean for us human beings
to say that guessing something with a
chance of being correct of 2 to the
minus 256
uh is to me exactly the same for all
intents and purposes as saying there
will be 2 to the power 256 universes in
one of which i guessed correctly in the
other one of which i guessed wrong
for all practical purposes for all uh
actionable
pragmatic purposes how should i behave
in this world those two situations are
exactly the same the fact that
in one out of the two to the power 256
universes
there is a version of me that got it
right means nothing to me it's it's
exactly the same as saying that there is
a 1 in two to the minus two two and one
in two to 256 chance that it would have
gotten it right that's what it means so
i don't think that that matters in any
uh real tangible sense
allison says could quantum networking be
used to build a telescope that spans
planets so no there's a simple answer
here but let me just very quickly
elaborate on this idea of quantum
networking namely there's no such thing
at least in the sense in which you
probably mean it remember there's
entanglement between particles that can
be separated by a large distance but you
can't use entanglement to send
information you can't use entanglement
to
i don't know run a telescope or
something like that entanglement is not
a tangible connection
if you want and there's different ways
of thinking about it of course different
ways of conceptualizing it but if you
want entanglement is a prediction
entanglement is a prediction for future
experimental outcomes it's a prediction
that if i measure one particle in one
state then when i go over to visit the
other particle it will be in another
state if those two particles were
entangled with each other that kind of
fact about
predicting the future is just not very
useful for building a telescope so maybe
you can build a telescope that spans
planets that's not to say that's
impossible but the way it will work is
you build some instrument on each planet
and then you just send the information
that one gets to the other one and
quantum mechanics has nothing to do with
it
stefan berniger says i very much like
your conversation with stephen wolfram
he has not yet shown that his approach
can actually explain our universe
but at least so far there's nothing
disproving his approach i am however not
sure how he will manage to overcome the
many orders of magnitude between the
scale which is reachable by computations
and the scale where observable physics
starts i am thus curious to hear your
many your main takeaways from this
conversation and if it somehow changed
your view on how to address the open
questions on a most fundamental level uh
so no i don't think it's changed my view
very much you know i think that
the
respectable way to think about what
wolfram is doing is
he's you know crossing his fingers
he's saying that the
there is a chance what he's trying to do
is guess the fundamental laws of physics
starting from almost nothing okay
starting from well there's some things
and there's some rules that's that's
basically the starting point now
maybe he'll get it right you know it's
possible
it's possible that you can guess the
laws of physics might evolve some trial
and error along the way
but
my experience as a scientist is that
it's not going to be that easy um
the world surprises us the world uh that
when we observe it when we measure it
when we interact with it empirically it
does things that we wouldn't have
guessed ahead of time
in particular
we have quantum mechanics right and
i think that you know there's only two
options for wolfram's project one is he
recovers quantum mechanics exactly and
the other is he doesn't those are the
two possibilities if he doesn't then
that's very very exciting because he
should be able to make a prediction that
deviates from the predictions of quantum
mechanics and that would be testable and
that would be great and it will either
work or it won't
but if he does get quantum mechanics
exactly then
i to me why not start with quantum
mechanics why are you trying to guess
some rules that will get you to quantum
mechanics
it would be fun to discover some even
more primitive rules
that get you to quantum mechanics but my
project is much more interested in
getting from quantum mechanics to the
observable world so to get from almost
nothing to quantum mechanics is fun and
interesting but not the way that i am
personally interested in pursuing
physics
not to say that he shouldn't do it or
other people shouldn't do it's just my
personal view
brad malt says in 1968 track and field
star bob beeman broke the world record
but for a long jump by almost two feet
this is a margin so big that it was
named one of the five greatest sports
moments in the 20th century by sports
illustrated and remains an olympic
record over 50 years later do you think
this amazing jump could have been an
instance of the wave function collapsing
to a very unlikely event the sport's
equivalent to putting one's fist through
a solid table
before you say this is too unlikely to
expect it to have happened consider that
the relevant universe of events may not
only be only long jumps in the summer
olympics but something much larger like
all athletic events in the summer
olympics or all athletic events in the
history of the universe were all muscle
contractions in the history of the
universe
okay so you know i think brad that this
is a very typical
mistake honestly
a mistaken way of reasoning so you're
saying that uh
is it possible that this particular
unlikely event was caused by this other
unlikely event and you're saying well on
the one hand sure an individual
case of this unlikely event is very
unlikely but on the other hand the
number of times that we've done events
is so large right so even an unlikely
event is bound to happen eventually
the clear mistake in that kind of
reasoning is it depends on how unlikely
the unlikely event is
no matter how many how large the space
of all events is
i can pick an unlikeliness so that none
of those events are likely to happen uh
none of these unlikely events
are likely to be one of these examples
the the obvious comparison is with um
the existence of intelligent
technological civilizations on other
planets right
there's a lot of planets in the
observable universe some huge number of
them
and so some people try to say well they
must have intelligent alien life on them
because there's so many planets well you
don't know because you don't know the
probability of there being other planets
intelligent life on any other planet if
the probability is 10 to the minus 100
then there's probably not intelligent
life anywhere else in our observable
universe
likewise you can't just say
there were a lot of athletic events in
the history of the universe or a lot of
muscle contractions you have to compare
it to the quantum probability of
something really dramatic happening on
this macroscopic scale so just to
illustrate this let's go through it
let's go through this in our heads in in
real time um
let's imagine let's be somewhat generous
like i don't know
how to estimate the number of muscle
contractions in the history of the
universe but let's let's imagine the
number of jumps that have been done by
human beings in the history of the
universe and again let's let's
overestimate it so that we're safe okay
so there's been about a hundred billion
human beings alive on earth throughout
history very fluffy speaking the details
are not going to matter here trust me
these specific numbers are not going to
matter here so 100 billion that's 10 to
the power 11 okay
human beings in the history of the
universe
and uh let's say they jump once every
three seconds
most human beings don't do that but
again we're overestimating okay
uh so there are three times ten to the
seven seconds in a uh year
so if a human being jumps once every
three seconds that is 10 to the seven
jumps per year per person so if there
are 10 to the uh
that's right yeah but you live for 100
years so for a person's lifetime it's 10
to the 9 jumps
per person's lifetime
and there's been 10 to 11 people so
that's 10 to the 20. that's how many
jumps people have done in history now
again
i don't know about you but i don't jump
once every second but still let's we're
overestimating okay so the true
statement is there are
equal to or less than the 10 to the 20
jumps being done in human history that's
a big number right it sounds like a lot
maybe one of them could have been a
macroscopic quantum event
a really really really unlikely but you
know it happens once in a while okay
clearly the number of
competition long jumps or competition
jumps of any sort is way smaller than 10
to the 20 but still let's let's stick
with 10 to the 20. how likely is it that
a macroscopic quantum fluctuation was
relevant to that jump well the bad news
is that roughly speaking
the
likelihood of a macroscopic quantum
fluctuation
is exponentially small in the number of
particles that you're talking about
fluctuating
so
let's this is not quite fair but it it
it paints a vivid picture here
let's say you need a gram of matter
to fluctuate right in your muscle to
make this relevant you probably need
more than that but let's imagine it's
that much so that's roughly speaking
again very very roughly avogadro's
number
of particles in a gram of matter
avogadro's number let's call it 10 to
the 23. it's it's more like 6 times 10
to 23 but we're rounding here we're
rounding down in this case so 10 to the
23 particles need to be involved in this
quantum fluctuation
but that doesn't mean
that the probability of the quantum
fluctuation is 10 to the minus 23 it
means the probability the quantum
fluctuation is roughly
10
to the minus 10 to the 23.
okay
that's why you don't see large quantum
fluctuations in the world that's why you
say sure i can bounce a ball off the
wall maybe it'll quantum tunnel through
it's unlikely to do it but the point is
it's really unlikely to do it so we're
taking the large number 10 to the 20 the
total number of jumps done by human
beings times the likelihood the
probability that one of them is a
macroscopically important quantum
fluctuation
but that probability is 10 to the minus
10 to the 23.
so the answer is
10 to the power
20
minus
10 to the 23 okay so it's a very very
very very very very tiny number
that's why you know you can't just say
things happen a lot therefore there
should be big quantum fluctuations
quantum fluctuations are really unlikely
and i know that for those of you who are
experts in quantum mechanics i'm doing a
very very sloppy
estimate for the likelihood of a quantum
fluctuation we haven't said what kind of
fluctuation it is etcetera etcetera but
the point stands the the probability of
big quantum fluctuations is really very
tiny
okay stephen bernard says
you're invited to host a panel
discussion of the greatest physicists of
all time living or dead language is no
barrier but you're limited to three who
would you pick
um so i don't yeah i mean
part of me wants to say
i don't care i don't like these kinds of
thought experiments because the the
there's an implicit idea in these
thought experiments that there is some
wisdom
that these people have that i would like
access to
uh i don't think that's true you know i
don't think there's any uh intrinsic
more intelligence on the part of these
dead people than there are on the part
of currently living people and i can
talk to the world's best physicists who
are alive right now i've had some of
them on my podcast
so you know what's the point and
the other thing besides intrinsic
intelligence is of course knowledge but
we have way more knowledge than those
folks have i've said it before and it's
not bragging but i know a lot more about
general relativity than einstein never
did that doesn't mean that i'm smarter
than einstein he invented it but we've
made progress and he died many decades
ago einstein didn't know about
black holes at all he certainly didn't
know about singularity theorems or or
anything like that he had a very fuzzy
knowledge of gravitational waves of
cosmology and and other things so
einstein doesn't have a lot to teach me
about general relativity is is the truth
of it um nevertheless the reason why i
did answer the question is because what
you might want is history that's what
you don't have history or biography or
something like that so really what
you're asking yourself is who are the
people who are the persons who are the
characters you would have liked to learn
something from about what was going on
at that time
uh given even given that uh caveat i
really don't know uh what the answer is
uh just so just to pick some people i
think galileo would be a good one like
he led a colorful life
and he you know galileo in many ways
really prefigured modern science like he
had a way of thinking that was super
duper ahead of his time that i think is
very interesting so i would have liked
to talk to him about that
um
no i mean aristotle would be interesting
because of lots of reasons but maybe
someone like democritus or epicurus or
lucretius one of the early atomists just
because we don't know a lot about what
their uh
discussions were like back then right we
don't know a lot of there's not a lot of
writings that survive so that would be
interesting and i guess the other one
would be ludwig boltzmann because you
know he wrestled with these deep
questions about um probability and the
nature of statistical mechanics and
sometimes he said things that were like
brilliant and very seeing and other
times he missed things they thought were
pretty obvious so i would like to know
you know what his thought process was
but these are all history questions i'm
not expecting to learn anything about
physics or philosophy from these folks
peter benham says
i know you have a distaste for it seems
but it seems logically obvious that it
had to be possible at the big bang for
emergent phenomena of high complexity
like life and consciousness to evolve
though it would seem impossible that one
would have conceived of such things by
just looking around at the raw materials
and yet here we are
what are potential higher order emergent
phenomena that seem impossible
that we might be able to conceive of
emerging eventually somewhere somehow
um yeah so i don't know i don't know
you're right i don't like this it seems
like like the previous question about
the quantum fluctuations you have to
work things out like it's just not good
enough to say it seems possible like
there's a probability of things
happening and you have to sit down and
do it that's why science is hard that's
why it's not just you know bs'ing around
the coffee table um so i don't know
exactly what is meant in this case by um
phenomena of high complexity to evolve i
mean presumably you mean
that
not
it was not possible for life to evolve
near the moment of the big bang but that
the possibility of life was inherent in
the materials and laws that were there
at the big bang is possible that
billions of years later things would
evolve and to us yes which i agree with
that um
but anyway with all that uh caveatting
out of the way
the the reason i'm not gonna give you a
good answer to this question but i can
try to explain why it's hard to give a
good reason um
you know the biggest reason why it's
hard is is we don't have that many
examples empirically of
complex information processing higher
order emergent phenomena right we have
life here on earth that's basically it
which is not to say that's the only
thing that could have happened but uh
the only way that the interesting if
you're interested in sort of the level
of complexity that you would begin to
characterize as a live or information
processing or conscious we only have one
example roughly speaking so it's very
hard to draw grand conclusions
there is one reason to be pessimistic
that there are very different kinds of
higher order emergent phenomena that
would have that level of complexity
namely that the universe doesn't last
forever
you know there's a competition going on
between the emergence of life and
complexity and the heat death of the
universe
being a conscious creature takes time
there are processes that go on in our
brains that take some amount of
resources and one of those resources is
duration is time so it took like we said
billions of years to get from
single-celled organisms to us
um and the universe is 14 billion years
old since the big bang so that's an
appreciable fraction of the entire age
of the universe and if you think about
stars uh burning you know lighting up
the universe
the
the rate of star formation the universe
already peaked
in star formation the number of stars
forming in the universe is on the
decline now
now individual stars can last a long
time if they're smaller stars they can
last you know a thousand billion years
right um or even longer than that but
they're very dim the the smaller stars
last longer but are dimmer so they have
a like less room but also a factor of a
thousand is nothing in this game
so
you can imagine
kinds of higher order emerging phenomena
on very different scales like
the galaxy becoming alive fred hoyle
wrote a
science fiction book about nebula coming
alive you could imagine replacing the
sort of energy source that for us is the
sun with hawking radiation from a black
hole which is much thinner and cooler
but maybe if you increase the time
scales appropriately something could
happen
but you would have to increase the time
scales by an enormous amount and the
universe might just not last that long
in a very realistic sense like all the
interesting stuff might die away and all
everything might fall into a big black
hole and evaporate away and there's
nothing outside the black hole to be
fueled by the hawking radiation
um so it actually is kind of tricky to
get the time scales to work out to give
you enough time to not only
have a thinking creature but to evolve
that thinking creature through the
process of something like natural
selection and and therefore at the end
of the day it's at least conceivable
that the other
possible kinds of thinking conscious
creatures in the universe are more or
less what we think of as organic life
they'll be very different than us
literally here on earth and you know
they might even use different dna base
pairs and stuff like that but i think
the basic chemistry
is going to be the same i don't think
you're going to see
living beings made out of photons or
made out of interstellar gas or anything
like that
again could be wrong but probably by the
time
for my lifetime we're not going to
discover it let's put it that way
krather lucca says what exactly does it
mean to be a moral constructivist is it
really different from being a moral
realist for example people often object
to moral realism by stating that there
can be no foundation for moral knowledge
to be built up from however when it
comes to physics and mathematics people
are far more willing to accept we are
exploring some objective reality rather
than merely constructing it but in
physics or mathematics there can be no
foundation for knowledge either we could
be tricked by a demon there's girdles in
completeness theorem etc
if we can't justify our beliefs in areas
like math and science more than in
morality then can we say that lacking a
foundation is not an impediment to
realism
because now there is a dichotomy between
moral knowledge on the one hand and
scientific and mathematical knowledge on
the other hand even though they all lack
a foundation so partly i wanted to read
this question because it's a good
advertisement for the podcast episode i
did on exactly this topic with uh justin
clark doan uh who draws connections
between the uh
status of objectivity and realism in
morality and mathematics
so i would distinguish and i i should
say ahead of time i'm not a super expert
at this either like i know a little bit
but this is not an area where my own
points of view are sufficiently
knowledgeable that they have hardened
into convictions you know i i have
feelings but they're very willing to be
changed if someone gives me a good
argument one way or the other but what
my feelings are is that
science and math and morality are three
very different areas like they're not
parallel to each other very much at all
in math you start with some axioms and
then you
prove theorems now even that is
even that is a contentious statement
that's what follows from girl's theorem
that there could be true statements that
are not derivable from a set of axioms
in a formal system but okay let's let's
put that aside the point is that i can
have different mathematical systems
whether or not you're thinking of them
axiomatically or some other way i can
have euclidean geometry non-euclidean
geometry i can have different but
equally consistent
sets of axioms for set theory etc okay
whereas in physics or in science there's
the world there's the real world and
there's one real world you know
rhetoric of the multiverse etc aside
count that all as one real world
there's one set of stuff doing something
that could have been otherwise right so
unlike math where you say well there's
some foundational principles axioms or
something equivalent to that and
different possible systems you can build
on that
there's different possible
physical systems but there's one real
one right as i said before i'm not a
modal realist i think there really is
something real about the individual real
world in which we live
now
it's not foundational right i agree with
you that we could be being tricked by a
demon or we could be boltzmann brains or
whatever
but science progresses under the
assumption the hypothesis that that's
not true that there is some basic
relationship that is not too tricky
between our sensory data and the real
world uh it's not immediate you know we
can be tricked there are optical
illusions and and so forth but we're not
being tricked by in in some
intentional way by an evil demon or
something like that and therefore
uh we can start with our sense data and
build up a picture of the real world
we just have to assume that we're not
being intentionally misled along the way
but it's a very different thing than
math in math we imagine different
possible mathematical structures and
they're all very conceivable in science
there's many different possible worlds
but only one of them is real
in morality it's completely different
morality neither one of those is true um
it's it's it's not that you have axioms
and you prove theorems and that's it
nor is it true that there's one right
system and you're looking for it
that's the essence of being a
constructivist morality to a
constructivist is a way of taking
our built-in
moral
impulses let's say which and i say built
in but that don't let that mislead you
um it could be that they're in part
instinctive but they also could be in
part that you learn them growing up and
they change over time etc but we all
have moral impulses we all have things
that we think of as right or wrong and
to a moral constructivist
what you think of as morality is just a
systematization and a rationalizing of
those moral impulses into a set of
beliefs which we call morality and
different people might have different
impulses so unlike physics where there's
only one real world different people
might be very
respectably and
correctly led to different moral
conclusions and then the moral
constructivist says
talk it out
you know sit down
talk to each other try to persuade each
other because the whole point is that
our in
sort of starting point moral impulses
are not coherent they don't necessarily
fit together they're not even
necessarily compatible with each other
we need to think about them we might
realize that oh let's downgrade this one
let's upgrade this one let's invent this
new one it's constantly a set of flux
and so there's not only no foundation
there's not even any reason to agree
between different people for moral
constructivists that doesn't mean that i
need to believe and accept what other
people think is morality that's the
difference between constructivism and
relativism i can say i think i'm right
and you're wrong but i don't think i'm
objectively right
i think that i'm right and i'm going to
try to convince you that i'm right but
there's no way that i can say you're
making a logical mistake if i don't
convince you of that whereas in math i
can say that you've made a mistake
proving your theorem and in physics i
can say your theory about how the world
works is wrong because of this
experiment there's no such thing that we
have access to in morality
okay i'm going to group two questions
together because they're about photons
and massless particles
alexander cordova says how is it that
massless particles like photons can have
a non-zero momentum
i've worked through a special relativity
chapter of an undergrad physics textbook
and there's an equation e squared equals
m c squared squared plus pc squared that
is to say energy squared let's set the
speed of light equal to one
so then energy squared is mass squared
plus momentum squared and then the same
textbook he says also gives the
following equation for relativistic
momentum p equals mv
divided by the square root of 1 minus v
squared
and he says no matter how i rearrange
these equations or try to plug in
various equivalent values if i plug in a
rest mass of 0 i get a momentum also
equaling zero
so uh and the other question i'm sorry
i'm not grouping together another
question i'm mentioning an answer so
thomas prunty gives an answer that is
half correct and half i disagree with so
let me say it so what thomas says is if
you put v equals c and m equals zero
into the relativistic expression you get
zero divided by zero so in other words
it's undefined so
um alexander got a misleading answer
that the momentum must be zero by first
plugging in mass equals zero and then
getting that the answer was zero but not
at the same time plugging in the
velocity was equal to the speed of light
if you do both of those at the same time
you get zero divided by 0 it's undefined
and i think the right way of saying that
is that
that equation momentum is mv divided by
the square root of 1 minus v squared
just doesn't apply to massless particles
that's supposed to be an equation that
only applies when the mass is not zero
the other equation e squared is m
squared plus p squared always applies
that one is always true for any kind of
particle
but then thomas goes to ruin it by
saying a photon is a quantum mechanical
object and so you don't need quant so
you do need quantum mechanics to get its
momentum relativity doesn't have an
opinion on the matter
that i have to take um issue with
because even though it's true that
photons are quantum mechanical objects
relativity certainly does have an
opinion on the matter within relativity
you're certainly welcome to talk about
particles uh with zero with that move at
the speed of light massless particles
particles with zero mass
in relativity is where you get the
answer that particles that have zero
mass will move at the speed of light and
their energy will be equal to their
momentum squared sorry the energy
squared is the momentum squared so e
equals p is the relationship between
energy and momentum for massless
particles and that's a perfectly
classical statement there's no obstacle
in principle to talk about classical
massless particles in relativity it so
happens that the real world and
therefore photons are quantum mechanical
but relativity would work perfectly well
anyway
okay
tom quine gives us a priority question
you wrote in from eternity to here that
entropy quite literally makes life
possible i have an inkling that entropy
is a motor of evolution the driving
force that requires things to either
persist or to perish can you make a
hypothetical argument for why this might
be true and a parallel argument for why
it might be the wrong way to look at
things um
no i can only give you an argument for
why it's true
because it is true but we need to be
careful about the sense in which it is
true okay
um the statement that entropy quite
literally makes life possible can be
justified by saying the following thing
what if there were no increasing entropy
in the universe what if the universe was
just in equilibrium right what if the
universe didn't have an entropy going up
at all
then you know nothing would happen
in equilibrium like if you have a gas in
a box and it's all in one corner and
it's low entropy and then you let it go
and it fills the box it reaches
equilibrium and then it stops evolving
life is a process as you already said
right life requires
dissipation into the universe and
dissipation means increasing the entropy
of things around it you know life is
time directed life is not like a
pendulum going back and forth life
remembers the past and doesn't remember
the future and so forth so to do all
that stuff that life does
it's
entropy does make it possible but the
particular aspect of entropy that makes
it possible is that it is possible for
entropy to increase
if you were at thermal equilibrium where
entropy could not increase then life
could not exist because you wouldn't
have any of that
rich set of irreversible processes going
on having said that
um
you can oversell the case when you say
entropy is the motor of evolution yeah i
would say that entropy is a necessary
condition for evolution that doesn't
quite mean the same thing as it's the
motor of it after all there's plenty of
cases where entropy increases without
evolution going on right without life
existing at all life is a particular
kind of complicated thing that requires
not only entropy to increase but other
things as well um
hang in there for a recent for an
upcoming podcast where we'll talk about
entropy in the arrow of time in
interesting ways
douglas albrecht says infinity and
infinitesimals seem to create challenges
in physics and it seems that they
require what seem like workarounds
energies at infinitely small distances
require cutoffs cosmology seems to blow
up the beginning of time et cetera
um quantizing space-time also seems to
be another way of dealing with this so i
wonder if maybe it's the math that needs
evolution to deal with limits or we are
just not equipped to deal with these
extreme points so i don't think it's the
math's fault um
you know maybe it is it's certainly a
possible idea so
think about the infinities of quantum
field theory like if the general problem
we're facing here is there are infinite
or undefined quantities in physics and
we need better math to understand them
the infinities in quantum field theory
are an example
where
in some sense better math came along and
helped us understand what was going on
feynman schwinger tomonaga dyson those
people showed us how to renormalize
quantum field theory which is basically
a fancy pants way of saying take a limit
where you have some function and you're
just trying you can't evaluate it at a
point but you can take a limit as it
gets closer and closer to that point and
find the same answer so they figured out
a way to do that in the case of quantum
field theory by using some fancy math
on the other hand we now know that
there's an even better way of thinking
about the infinities of quantum field
theory which is the wilsonian way ken
wilson
showed that if you just
take seriously the fact that you don't
know what's happening
at very very high energies very very
short distances you can still do quantum
field theory you can do effective
quantum field theory
and honestly all of these infinities
came about because you were just taking
infinite energies and zero wavelengths
too seriously
what right did you have to do that you
know i mean probably space time itself
could potentially break down at those
points so wilson said that the existence
of the infinities in the first place was
a mistake and so in some sense you
didn't need fancier math to deal with
them and i think that that's more along
my
guess as to how things are going to go
that it's not that you're going to need
fancier math to deal with all these
things is that you're going to realize
that the underlying physics is a little
bit simpler or a little bit less
dramatic than it seemed to be but of
course there's different situations here
we'll have to see how it goes
okay i'm going to group three questions
together about black holes and
information
about unitarity matt hickman says from
my understanding one of the guiding
principles used to think about black
hole information is that information is
not destroyed in quantum mechanics if i
were a believer in the copenhagen
interpretation i might say that
information is destroyed all the time a
wave function happily evolves according
to the schrodinger equation and then you
measure it and information is gone
umberto nani says may you please comment
on what is lost if unitarity is lost
like which parts of the current theories
would be affected
and rich hogg says hawking radiation is
usually described as emerging in a
specific thermally randomized
configuration
but under the many worlds interpretation
wouldn't we more correctly think of it
as merging into a superposition of all
possible configurations which then
decohere into specific configurations in
separate branches
so
all of these so let me come comment on
humberto's question first because i want
to just define what's going on the
question is what is lost if unitarity is
lost so unitarity is just the fancy
physicist term for obeying the
schrodinger equation roughly speaking
okay if you think about what the
schrodinger equation tells you if you
have some wave function some quantum
state the schrodinger equation is
deterministic
it evolves one wave function given some
hamiltonian aka some laws of physics it
evolves the wave function over time in a
perfectly predictable way and famously
or infamously in quantum mechanics
that's half the story the other half of
the story is what happens when you
measure a quantum mechanical system and
then it's not unitary the wave function
collapses and it's unpredictable it's
not deterministic so
if so when we talk about unitarily being
important in physics
it is
implicit
that we're talking about the part of
evolution where we're not measuring it
okay so whenever physicists worry about
the black hole information loss problem
they go ah unitarity blah blah blah
they all know that unitary is violated
when you make a measurement but they're
just not saying that because they're
talking about a system as a black hole
it's out there just doing its thing it's
not being measured that's that's the
implicit idea
now
i'm not sure if that's okay you know i
think that physicists because they don't
fret about the foundations of quantum
mechanics tend to be sloppy about these
issues and they
sometimes will say oh you must be
unitary and other times you'll say well
of course you're not unitary when you
measure and etc and they don't tell you
exactly what is meant by a measurement
etc etc etc so i think we should worry
about that a little bit to directly uh
answer humberto's question if the
fundamental laws were not unitary um so
if schrodinger's equation was not
correct right
that's different that's a much more
radical thing than saying that uh
when you measure it's not unitary
because we all know from things like
many worlds interpretation that you can
have a theory that is overall perfectly
unitary and yet effectively within
observable branches it looks non-unitary
so if you had really fundamental laws of
physics that were not unitary well then
that would depend it would depend on how
you didn't have unitarity
it could go very wrong very very quickly
uh there were there were papers um years
ago that said you know like energy
conservation could be dramatically
violated if you violated unitarity all
of the tests we've done on precision
electroweak measurements and things like
that and particle physics could be very
very wrong
but then there are other ways you could
be non-unitary
that are okay like there are theories
like objective collapse theories of
quantum mechanics penrose grw etc which
do violate unitarity in that sense so it
depends there's only one way to be
unitary there's an infinite number of
ways to be non-unitary so it depends is
the is the answer
now to matt's question you know what
about the fact that information is
destroyed all the time
and to rich's question you know in in
many worlds
uh
you evolve into all possible
configurations and then decohere
yes yeah the implicit ideas in both of
your questions are correct but i think
you need to be careful here and in fact
i am sufficiently convinced you need to
be careful that i wrote a paper about it
so i wrote a paper well i co-authored a
paper um called black hole
ah what was the name of my paper
um
branches of the wave function need not
contain black hole firewalls something
like that our idea was the following
that the firewall argument was a popular
thing that people were thinking about
over the last 10 years
it's said that you can't simultaneously
have the entanglement of
particles virtual particles escaping
from black holes and falling in
near the event horizon causing hawking
radiation and get all the information
out of a black hole and therefore they
suggested breaking the entanglement near
the horizon which gives rise to a
firewall
and what we suggested in my paper and
this i hope i get all the um authors
here because i was working with a whole
bunch of grad students on a whole bunch
of different papers at the time this is
with grant remin
ning bao and aiden chatwin davis i'm
pretty sure
um
i should really look that up i'm going
to look that up as i'm talking here but
our point was look
uh the when you say the two things are
entangled with each other uh two quantum
mechanical systems that statement
depends on where you are in the wave
function of the universe that is to say
on what branch you're in in the wave
function of the universe
oh yes and jason pollock i knew i was
forgetting jason's name so the name of
the paper is branches of the black hole
wave function need not contain firewalls
so let's say you have two particles
let's say they are entangled with each
other okay alice and bob have their two
spins you have two particles and they're
entangled and then you measure one of
them you're alice you measure your
particle you see it spin up but now you
know the other particle is spin down
what does a many worlds person say a
mini world's person says well now
there's a branch where the particle
alice's particles spin up bob's a spin
down and another branch where the
opposite is true
but on
both of those branches
alice's particle and bob's particle are
no longer entangled
they are entangled in the wave function
of the universe because they were before
and you didn't stop that but on the
individual branches they're not so
that's the point that we tried to make
and actually other people have made
related points before
um but the point is that
if you don't take seriously
the measurement process and decoherence
and many worlds then you can be sloppy
about what needs to be entangled with
what because two subsystems can be
entangled in the wave function of the
universe even though they're not
entangled on the branch where you're
measuring it and so
we tried to make the argument there were
more than enough degrees of freedom in
the black hole that on every branch of
the wave function
you could see the particles near the
horizon be entangled and therefore have
no firewall even though in the um
wave function as a whole there is enough
entanglement between the in the hawking
radiation at early times and late times
to restore unitarity anyway that's
probably not making any sense if you
haven't read the paper but the point is
i'm agreeing with the general philosophy
of these two questions that
when it comes to careful questions about
black hole information being lost it
might pay to be a little bit more
precise about what you mean about
measurement and unitarity and
decoherence and all of those things
demon hat says would you rather have
legs as long as your fingers or fingers
as long as your legs fully functioning
and why uh i think it's i think i gotta
go with the fingers as long as your legs
right long fingers sounds better than
short legs
but the other thing i want to say about
this question is
you know if we do imagine
different alien life forms i think that
we tend to be a little bit less
imaginative than we should be about how
different they could be than us
you know if you just had fingers as long
as your legs for some reason that
evolution gave them to you i can imagine
you'd think of those as perfectly
sensible logical like you know you're
just natural like you don't go oh man i
wish that my fingers were shorter
um but i don't know what they're going
to be like you know especially just with
basic things like size you know aliens
that we see
in movies
are normally human sized maybe a little
bit bigger a little bit smaller whatever
but we rarely see intelligent
technologically advanced aliens that are
one millimeter in size or a hundred
meters in size or a thousand meters in
size right um i think we should be more
open-minded about what these
possibilities are i said earlier in the
ama
intelligent aliens made out of photons
or something like that might be
implausible but we could imagine very
very different sizes and shapes than we
actually see
paul hess says what is your method to
choose which papers to read out of the
near infinite deluge do you have several
passes where were you forced to skim
many papers then from that set choose a
smaller subset to reread more closely or
do you read papers others are talking
about in your circles
these days it's more the latter um
but you know
it's a complicated thing and it's going
to depend on how you know the style of
your research that you're doing at any
one time
it used to be like i really did try to
keep up on all the papers that came out
in theoretical cosmology and particle
physics at least to the extent of
looking at their titles and abstracts
there is a morning mailing that you can
either get in the email or you can check
online
from the archive that tells you in your
specific subfields of physics what are
the recent papers
but you know
my own research has gone away from that
so i used to just do sort of the former
option that you list which is look at
all the papers the ones that looked
interesting enough that they'd be
relevant to my research i would print
out and then hopefully read at some
point
these days i'm thinking about more
long-term things you know i'm not
chasing ambulances
um and the number of people working on
the same questions as i am is relatively
small and those papers appear they're
relatively sparse on the archive etc so
i more
rely on people i know and other papers i
read to point me to things that are
relevant you know this is why i tell my
students when you write papers it's good
to reference other people's papers it's
actually not only is it you know
ethically the right thing to do to put a
lot of citations in your papers
but it makes them more discoverable
right like sometimes a great way to find
papers that are relevant to a particular
question is to go to a you know there's
different services on the internet like
inspire is one for particle physics
where you not only can see what papers
are cited by a certain paper but you can
see what papers cite a certain paper so
if you discover a paper that's really
important to you
then you can see who else has been
writing about that toward the future of
when that paper was published so that is
extremely helpful and therefore by
putting more citations in your paper you
make your paper more discoverable to
more people which is always a good thing
sam cox says i wonder if the missing
anti-matter problem the bariogenesis
problem is somehow connected to the
mysteries of dark matter and dark energy
perhaps the missing anti-matter was
sponged up by or morphed into dark
matter at an earlier moment in the big
bang is it reasonable to expect there
exists dark anti-matter
actually i forgot i'm going to group
this with another question andrew vermin
vernon smith says can you explain
whether or not it's possible that the
weak force may have been involved
somehow in bringing about the universe
including time in space by the big
banger otherwise
and if so whether it's possible that the
right-handed matter and left-handed
anti-matter
may have proceeded backward in time
since only left-handed matter and
right-hand anti-matter interact with the
weak force in our forward-in-time
reality so the
connection between these two questions
is matter and anti-matter um somehow
being connected with bigger cosmological
questions and there is a paper there was
a paper that was written um about a
scenario similar to what andrew was
talking about by latham boyle kieran
finn and neil turock a couple years ago
about a cpt symmetric universe where
they suggested
that um in a way like you know morally
similar to what jennifer chan and i
suggested uh years ago and um
anthony aguirre former mindscape guest
and steven gratton suggested around the
same time a back-to-back universe where
there was sort of a throat or a middle
point and then one part of the universe
goes forward in time and the other goes
in the opposite direction of course both
sides of the universe have people in
them that call the direction toward the
throat the past right so it's a
two-sided time kind of scenario
the spin that boyle and finn and turock
put on it was exactly this kind of idea
that there was a violation not only of
time symmetry
between the two halves but cpt symmetry
which relates matter and anti-matter and
also right-handedness and
left-handedness so roughly speaking sort
of more matter on one side more
anti-matter on the other side i haven't
looked into that scenario very carefully
but you're welcome to look it up just
google cpt symmetric universe and you
will find it
relating that to sam's question um
perhaps the missing anti-matter was
sponged up into dark matter and early
moment the big bang
there are scenarios like that also um
so especially here here's something that
you can think about the total amount of
dark matter in our universe is around
five times by mass as much ordinary
matter in the universe okay
and
that's a small number five is not very
big number like in principle these two
numbers are completely unconnected you
know the usual ways that we have of
predicting the amount of dark matter and
the amount of
ordinary matter are just completely
unrelated to each other so why are they
so close in density a factor of five
well maybe the theory goes the dark
matter particle is and this is one
version of the theory there's other
versions of it but one version is
maybe
for every proton in the universe there
is one dark matter particle that weighs
five times as much of a proton right and
so maybe there's some process that takes
baryon number and splits it so that
positive baryon number goes into
ordinary matter negative baryon number
goes into anti-matter in some sense and
that's why there's more dark matter
did i say antimatter negative barrier
number goes into dark matter is what i
meant to say
maybe that's why there's five times as
much dark matter as ordinary matter
it doesn't you know those kind of
scenarios don't sort of
easily fit together like you know
in theoretical physics what you get to
realize that some
theories some models some frameworks
that you propose
once you propose them everything just
fits and just works and everything is
great others you kind of have to
struggle to make them work a little bit
and this is more of the latter but
that's not to say that we just haven't
thought of the right way to do it
finally you say is it reasonable to
expect there exists dark anti-matter
yeah it's perfectly reasonable um we
don't know for sure one way or another
but if you think of all the different
ways to have a relic abundance of dark
matter
most of them
predict that there is an equal amount of
dark matter and dark antimatter or that
there's no difference so
you know like photons for example don't
have anti-particles they interact with
each other they can be created or
destroyed but they're they're bosons so
you can't really distinguish their
photons are neutral bosons right so
there's not a real difference between a
photon and anti-photon that's why you
don't talk about it
if the dark matter is a neutral boson
like the axion for example then there
wouldn't be dark antimatter because
there's just no such thing as an
anti-axion on the other hand if the dark
matter is a fermion which many wimp
models are weakly interacting massive
particles
then the theory is that at some point
you know the dark matter and the dark
antimatter were just
annihilating with each other in the
early universe when it was very dense
but they are only interacting weakly
with each other so when the density goes
low enough
they just don't find each other
it becomes rare for a dark particle and
a dark anti-particle to bump into each
other there's no long-range force
between them
like electromagnetism there's only a
very very short-range weak nuclear force
so the two particles have to come very
very close together to actually
annihilate and that is the standard
picture of weakly interacting dark
matter so in the wimp model you expect
there to be half dark matter half dark
antimatter
or versions where once again there's no
difference between matter and antimatter
in that sector
which is why you can still hope
that in regions where you expect the
density of dark matter to be very high
like at the center of a galaxy
maybe you still see some dark matter and
dark antimatter annihilating into gamma
rays and you can detect it that way that
was a big hope for the fermi space
telescope to look for gamma rays from
dark matter the sad news about the fermi
space telescope is they found a lot of
gamma rays but it's really easy to make
gamma rays even if uh they have nothing
to do with dark matter so maybe some of
them are due to dark matter but we just
don't know
so far we've been able to find less
exotic explanations for all the gamma
rays that we were able to observe
okay tony b says this question is
inspired by the recent movie tenet
which engages with ideas on the entropic
arrow of time more than many
you've spoken many times about how we
remember the past because in that
direction our extrapolations are pinned
down by the low entropy boundary
condition of the beginning of the
universe if the low entry boundary
condition were in the other direction we
would remember in that direction the
same way
do you have any intuition as to what
kinds of events could happen at the
boundary between two regions of a
universe one region having a low entropy
boundary condition in one direction and
the other having a low entropy boundary
condition in the other
no i don't
i can give you a feeling for why it
would be weird but i don't have a well
thought out model for exactly what
things would be like
it would be weird because
things would seem to you to start acting
in ways
that were anti-entropic right that were
sort of uh despite your best efforts
lowering the entropy of the universe
which is just a weird thing right
packs of cards spontaneously organizing
themselves into
uh order two three four five six
etcetera um cream and coffee on mixing
uh glasses unbreaking things like that
you know craig calendar who is a
philosopher of physics who thinks about
these things uh gave you a thought
experiment wrote down a thought
experiment where you know it's like
there's a prediction a low entropy
boundary condition is precisely a
precognition event where you know what's
going to happen in the future and you
can't stop it so the example he gave was
you know someone tells you that on a
certain date all the world's paper jay
eggs are going to assemble themselves
into a certain drawer in a certain room
and you say well no i'm going to stop it
right i'm going to like put up guards
and prevent it from happening but all
sorts of crazy things start going wrong
you know the guards are sick and someone
drops the egg and it like gets mistaken
for something else and eventually they
end up there right in that drawer and
you're like how in the world is this
happening and it would seem
spooky and magical it would seem like
some intelligent force is working
against you now
that's not the whole story
because if you were truly at the
boundary
then there's one of two possibilities
either
there could be living beings remember i
said before living beings require that
entropy is increasing right they
dissipate
so either there be two types of living
beings which dissipated in opposite
directions which would be very weird or
more likely would just be impossible for
there to be any living beings at all
near that boundary
but again i don't think anyone has
really worked out the details of what
that would be like
jeff babon says i'm trying to understand
how much of the twin paradox is due to
the fact that one twin accelerates while
the other doesn't if i have a circular
track one light year in radius and i'm
traveling around the track near the
speed of light i will feel a centripetal
acceleration if this track is next to
earth then as i pass it my twin brother
and i will synchronize our watches
by the time i come around again i think
i will have aged more slowly to my twin
even though we've both been feeling
acceleration approximately 1g the entire
time if that's true what makes my frame
of reference special as it is because is
it because only i have moved relative to
the universe as a whole so no it is not
because you've moved relative to the
universe as a whole and um
i've said this before but i'll also try
to say it again i would just forget
about words like frames of reference
right or acceleration or any of these
things none of this is the point
the time dilation special relativity is
exactly the same
as saying that if i have two paths
between two points in space
those two paths can be different lengths
that's it that's all that there is to it
if i put two dots on a piece of paper
and ask two people to connect them with
a curve one of those curves is going to
be shorter than the other and if one
curve is as short as possible it will be
a perfectly straight line
any
non-straight line will be longer right
and that's exactly the same thing that
happens with the twin paradox except in
time rather than in space any
non-straight line is shorter in time
experiences less time so it's not that
it has to do with acceleration the point
of the twin paradox is not acceleration
the point is the length of your
trajectory in space time of course the
rule is that the longest duration path
has no acceleration
so therefore if you do accelerate then
you're going to experience less time
okay so that's the that's where
acceleration comes in but it's not
because it's primary it's not because
the acceleration is causing
the aging in any sense so tim maudlin
actually we mentioned um
books about philosophy of science so tim
maldon in one of his philosophy of
science books has a very good
illustration of this point uh you know
think about the usual twin paradox setup
where one person just stays home forget
about the acceleration you feel on earth
that's a complication that we don't need
to worry about one zooms out on a rocket
ship and then accelerates and zooms back
okay so there's sort of a triangle that
you draw in space time in your mind
between the long edge being the
stationary twin and then the two shorter
edges with a bend in between being the
twin that goes out on the rocket
so you might think that it's the
acceleration at that turnaround point
that is doing the work okay
but
tim says well imagine
the same amount of acceleration but
along a different path namely
the the first path was accelerate a lot
outward but then coast and then turn
around so you accelerate again and then
coast and then accelerate finally to
land at the same point you started with
so three bouts of acceleration just put
those three bouts of acceleration much
closer to each other okay so accelerate
out immediately accelerate back and then
accelerate to stop so you get a much
tinier triangle and then you sit there
along the same path okay
in this case you've done the same amount
of acceleration as the first thought
version of the experiment where you went
way out and came way back you just did
it all quicker you did it you didn't
have the long coasting periods in
between okay
but the difference in time experienced
by the two twins is much smaller in that
second difference in that second example
because the length of the path is much
closer
than much closer to the original
stationary twin so the acceleration
allows you to have a different length
path through space time but it's not the
point it's not the causing of the of the
difference in time duration it's the
length of the path that is the cause of
the time duration being different
okay jeff b says you've stated that you
are against the idea of teleology
underlying physics however it seems as
if this would be difficult to judge
after all the laws of physics may be
progressing towards some final
teleological state but the path that it
takes is simply too complex for us to
notice or understand in fact it seems
logical based on the fact that matter
tends toward the lowest energy state
this is reminiscent of the ancient
notion of elements wanting to rise or
fall what do you make of this
so
i'm not against
underlying physics i just don't think
it's there the laws of physics as we
currently understand them have no
teleology in them and there is no
problem that we are faced with under
current knowledge of the physical world
that is solved by teleology so i just
think it was a an old idea that we can
get rid of you mention um the idea that
matter tends towards the lowest energy
state but of course that's not true
because energy is conserved right at
least to the classical limit right
what you mean when you say matter tends
towards the lowest energy state is that
if you have a
dissipation full system
if you have a system with friction
then the system will in fact go to the
lowest energy state but what it's doing
is increasing the entropy of the
universe
and that is not because there is some
future high entropy boundary condition
it's because high entropy is natural
so the thing is that ordinary
dissipation full systems
uh tumbling down to their lowest energy
state doesn't require any future
condition at all it's just the natural
thing to expect to happen just as
entropy is increasing is natural so
there's no reason for teleology and
there's no evidence for it that's why i
don't think it's an interesting thing to
think about that's not to say that i
would mind if if we got new information
that changed our minds
george attensoff says are you concerned
about carbon emissions
we begin we've begun using electric car
transportation battery manufacturing
though is very carbon intensive and the
subsequent battery recycling or disposal
will create a nightmare 20 years from
now and there's more details in there
so roughly speaking yes i'm concerned
about carbon emission but you know you
can't the various arguments you put
forward in the question
are all words and that's not enough you
know just exactly as i said with other
questions earlier sometimes you got to
do the math so on the one hand burning
fossil fuels emits carbon
fossil fuel
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere on
the other hand various parts of the
electric vehicle cycle also emit
greenhouse gases into the air but you
can't just say well they both are bad
therefore they're equal you got to
measure it you got to actually do the
calculation so people have done the
calculation counting not only
the power that goes to actually charge
the batteries of the electric car but
also the mining
and the manufacturing process and the
waste process and so forth and roughly
speaking to the best of my understanding
the
answer is that an electric car
gives off about one-third of the carbon
emissions of an equivalent
uh internal combustion engine car so
it's way less roughly speaking uh so
it's a it's a
kick in the right direction it'll be
much better if we can actually get that
electricity from solar power or
something like that rather than burning
coal for it okay but you know but my my
actual answer to the question is you
have to do the math and so far the math
that's been done indicates electric
vehicles are much better for the planet
than uh fossil fuel burning vehicles are
chris says most of your discussions of
philosophy that i've heard seem to be
within a western framework what are your
thoughts on others such as eastern
philosophy this relates to the topic of
meta philosophy uh do you have any
easily summarizable views on that i
don't think i have any easily
summarizable views on that you know my
view about philosophy is i i care about
what's right and wrong i'm not uh i'm
interested in the history of philosophy
to the extent that it's cool and
interesting but to the practical extent
of trying to understand the world i
don't care whether a good idea comes
from eastern or western or whatever and
typically the best ideas are relatively
recent
not because recent people are smarter
but because they're building on ideas
from a long time ago
um so what i'm thinking about you know
what happened at the big bang or the
quantum measurement problem
there's no difference in my mind between
eastern and western philosophy like
wherever the good idea comes from i care
about having said that of course you're
right that when i've been discussing
philosophy my touchstones are western
philosophy that's what i'm trained in to
the extent that i'm trained at all um so
that's that's my my bag of tricks you
know the knowledge base that i'm working
from um
not from any conscious disparagement of
eastern philosophy so clearly what i
should do is have a podcast episode
about eastern philosophy hmm
let's see if that happens soon stay
tuned for that
okay two more questions i'm grouping
together
sandra stuckey says in the podcast with
elizabeth strahalski there's a c in her
name that doesn't get pronounced
strahalski the idea that cells are
information processors and climb entropy
gradients came up again
how is the idea that physical biological
computational systems process
information and make choices or use
strategies to optimize certain outcomes
compatible with the purely deterministic
evolution of the universe in what sense
can an organism or self-replicating
piece of chemistry influence its its
future
that kind of presupposes that there were
alternative futures to begin with that
information about the environment can
truly be exploited
then the other question somewhat related
is from jason who says you've said
before in answering questions about free
will versus determinism that as a
compatibilist
you find the interesting question to be
about how to operationalize that so how
do you operationalize that when does it
make sense to treat people as if they
have free will and when does it not
so the point is um
so i can't give a very good answer to
jason's question i think it's a hard
question a good question it requires
more work and i'm not an expert but i'll
talk about a little bit uh to sandra's
question i can be a little bit more
specific you know
the question in what sense can organism
or self-replicating piece of chemistry
influence its future this presupposes
there are alternative futures to begin
with well there are
our alternative futures
as far as the person knows or as a
self-replicating piece of chemistry
knows
you know i think
if i'm a person or a bacterium or
whatever in this day and age i happen to
know that i made a particles or a
quantum wave function and there are some
laws of physics underlying it okay
but what if i didn't know that like that
doesn't change my everyday life very
much uh if i didn't know that what would
i how would i act right i don't know
what's going to happen in the future and
you can say yes but laplace's demon
knows i'm not laplace's demon i'm not
friends with laplace's demon i can't get
any information from losses demon about
this
to
every single
in every single sense that is relevant
to me
thinking about the future there are a
whole bunch of possible alternative
futures
and my choices will help bring them
about
as i've said before in talking about
free will literally every human being
acts that way there are no human beings
that truly act like they don't make
choices about the future there are
people who like certainly if you're
leaving comments on patreon you're
trying to
either learn something or influence
something you're trying to have a causal
effect on the future that's why you're
doing it right you there's simply no
coherent way to talk about human action
without opening without involving the
idea that we have a causal influence on
the future due to the choices that we
make so that's the easy part of the
question um what jason is saying is okay
there are conditions where we don't have
a causal impact on the future like when
you're asleep
when you're unconscious then you're not
making any choices about the future
maybe your brain is turning but you're
not operationalizing it as you say
um in other cases you know if you if you
uh have lost capacity somehow if you've
lost mental capacity or even physical
capacity uh there's famous cases where
you have a brain tumor
arguably when you're addicted to
something you just have no choice in
some sense so then the question is
how do you really draw the line between
we should treat you as having had a
choice and we should treat you as not
having had a choice i think it's a good
question i think that there are easy
cases there are easy edge cases right if
you're asleep you're not making choices
if you're awake and competent and
deciding what shirt to wear
that day you're making a choice right
but there are fuzzy cases in between and
i think that the lesson of that is that
we should think hard
about what exactly should be done at
that boundary where there are fuzzy
cases the lesson should not be because
the boundary is fuzzy the boundary
doesn't exist or because the boundary is
fuzzy we should treat everything as if
it's either deterministic or
indeterministic right sometimes you got
to live with the fuzziness sometimes you
have to live with the idea that these
human ideas these coarse-grained
macroscopic emergent phenomena
are fuzzy
that's okay there's many things that are
fuzzy i think that right and wrong are
fuzzy so i don't think that's an
argument against taking it seriously so
sorry for not giving you a once and for
all answer jason but i don't have a once
and for all answer even though i'm
convinced we should be looking for the
best answers that we can invent
preston justice says you've been
successful dabbling in philosophy
therefore is it logical or realistic to
assume that one could go
counterclockwise
and find their way into contributing to
the sciences without shutting up and
calculating from the field of philosophy
of science physics in the humanities
department
sure it's absolutely possible
but it's work you know it's not easy
so
the word dabbling is the wrong word to
use you have to do the work you have to
uh in particular you have to take
seriously
both the knowledge base and the
expertise of people who already do this
thing
so you know it's it that that work is
less visible if you're moving from
science to philosophy because if you
want to become knowledgeable about
what's going on in philosophy you read
or you talk to people whereas if you
want to become knowledgeable about
what's going on in science you might
need to have a laboratory or something
like that right this can happen we had
an example not that long ago um
uh and sophie barwich right who talked
about the philosophy of smell is trained
as a philosopher and now she has a lab
where she studies uh the sense of smell
in the lab so you can absolutely do that
there's other people who think about
consciousness etc who are
philosophically trained and then move
into
directly experimental science
for physics yeah sure i mean for people
who are philosophers of physics
with a good background in physics many
of them do things that are just
indistinguishable from doing physics and
you could even imagine
falling in love with a particular
physics problem that had no more
connection with philosophy
but again
you just have to have respect
for the existing knowledge base in those
fields then you can do whatever you want
that would be my attitude
david wright says the latest podcast
with elizabeth strahalski on synthetic
cells was fascinating and touched on
some of the same exciting questions
about the boundary between physics
chemistry and biology that michael levin
is dealing with in his work on
morphogenesis at tufts
you ended up discussing whether living
systems actually require a cell membrane
and if it was possible there was a more
general synthetic form of biological
systems this reminded me of carl fristen
who has identified a model for
biological systems based on his free
energy principle another previous
mindscape guest
the model identifies internal states
external states active states and
sensory states that operate to minimize
the difference between a known internal
state and a bayesian predicted external
state a cell membrane may simply be an
evolved way to limit the computational
bandwidth needed to process the model
algorithm by reducing the number of
internal state variables what the cell
model and non-cell model share in common
is that they would both be based on
markov blankets with different scales
and numbers of states so the question is
do you think dr strahlsky should
consider fristen's model in her research
so i'm not going to give elizabeth any
advice about what to do for her research
she knows much better than i do what the
relevant uh things that could be helpful
are but i do think that fristen's model
is very interesting and worth taking
seriously let me put it that way um
what i don't know is whether it's
uh so what the way i think about it is
the following um
when we look at real living beings
cells are the basic building block right
and cells are not just collections of
atoms and molecules they're a specific
kind of collection of atoms and
molecules that are compartmentalized in
a very clear way right there's a lipid
bilayer
that surrounds the cell and acts as the
cell wall and there's an inside and
outside and there's internal structure
inside that grows through evolutionary
history and so forth so the question is
is this just a an accident could it have
been completely otherwise could there be
no cell walls is it convenient is it you
know useful to have a cell wall but not
necessary or is it absolutely necessary
is there no other way to make life
one of the things that elizabeth does in
her research is non-cellular bio
synthetic biology so she studies um
biological
processes in
artificial environments that are not
surrounded by cell walls at all
but
my point is that uh i don't know the
answer to this question of whether cell
membranes are necessary helpful or
completely accidental i think that what
fristen has done is given good reason to
believe it's not just an accident which
i was very willing to believe anyway so
it doesn't require much information as a
good bayesian my prior was already up
there
but what he's saying is here's a way in
a very abstract high level sense of
thinking of the usefulness the role
played by that cell membrane uh as a way
of sort of limiting the bandwidth of
information that comes back and forth
between uh the external world and the
internal world that makes perfect sense
to me um
there's a huge danger
that we already know the answer and so
we're inventing a story after the fact
so i'm not sure that that is the only or
even best way to think about the
usefulness of cell membranes maybe it is
um but i think that's you know this is
stuff that my impression is it's
cutting-edge stuff that is to say
there's not settled answers that people
agree on um that might just be because i
don't know the field very well or but it
might be because biology is hard and
when we're working on it i certainly
think that that kind of idea is very
useful very very very interesting let's
put it that way very worth following up
on
brendan says
i was re interested in reading your
textbook space time and geometry but i
was wondering how much prior knowledge
in mathematics and physics is roughly
required i have all of your other books
and followed along to the biggest ideas
in the universe but was unsure whether
that would still be enough without a
rigorous understanding of the underlying
math and physics my background is in
computer science and has been over 10
years since i took a differential
equations class
well you know it's always hard to say um
the goal of the book
is to be self-contained so it's not
assuming that you have a lot of
prerequisites
but if you're not used to thinking in
certain ways the material can be very
very intimidating you know it's it's
more a matter of is the materials
sufficiently similar to things that
you're used to seeing that it's not too
scary
uh or do you or do you just say like i
have no idea what all these symbols mean
it's not a matter of explicit prior
knowledge so much as a matter of being
ready to handle this kind of thing the
one example the one counter example of
that is you do need to be pretty
comfortable with differential equations
in particular partial differential
equations you have to be able to know
what a partial differential equation is
it'd be very very helpful if you were
used to seeing solutions to the wave
equation and things like that
because we're going to very quickly
use that
invent new notation that you haven't
used before and you have if you're
grasping both what the equations are and
the new notation that's much harder than
just looking at the new notation so
the single thing
that is probably the shortest distance
between um
very basic background knowledge and that
gr book is actually something like a
good
uh e m book electricity and magnetism a
good e m book being one that uses
special relativity in a very um
uh central way like you can do e m
e even though electricity and magnetism
allah maxwell was the inspiration for
special relativity
it was invented before special
relativity so you can certainly learn
electricity magnetism without
putting it into that special relativity
context but it can be put into the
special relativity context and once you
do that your transition to general
relativity will be much much quicker and
easier so that's what i would say i'm
trying to think of
an example of a good book i'm not super
familiar with the
textbook landscape on electromagnet uh
electricity magnetism i believe there
was a book by ohanian hans ohanian that
i liked and really used special
relativity in a central way so that
might be a good warm-up
richard graff says try as i might i
can't grasp the connection between
symmetry and conservation laws as worked
out in northern theorem
can you explain the relationship in
relatively non-technical terms or is
this one of those somethings deeply
hidden that requires an understanding of
the math to comprehend yeah you know
it's a good question i did um
want to cover
nerd's theorem when i did the biggest
ideas in the universe videos and i ended
up doing it there it is in there
in the video on symmetry i talk about
nerd's theorem and i give a little
argument in favor of it now it requires
work because
um
you first need to understand the
lagrangian formulation of classical
mechanics once you understand
lagrangians you can then understand a
little bit about symmetry and then you
can understand earth's theorem so
there's a bit of technical background
required one way or the other and oh i
should be honest i
roughly speaking got that explanation of
nervous theorem that i gave uh from
feynman from like the findman lectures
on physics or something like that i i
believe that was the book where it was
from
um
and you know to be honest it's not
intuitive really like
when i say intuitive it depends on what
your intuition is
sometimes you've been using lagrangians
for long enough in your life that things
become intuitive that weren't intuitive
before you use lagrangians but it's
definitely not something where you could
hand wave to a person on the street and
get them to see not just what nerd the
theorem says but the proof for why it's
true i don't know
you know a
high school level way of saying
why how the proof and the theorem
actually works out it'd be interesting
to get that but you know it might not be
possible because nurture's theorem only
applies
to classical systems for which there
exists a lagrangian description okay
there are systems for which node's
theorem doesn't apply so i suspect that
you need to know what lagrangian is to
get there that's my suspicion
rebecca lashua says or leshwa
do you agree with max tegmark's basic
premise that the universe is essentially
mathematical in nature certainly a
complete theory of everything would be
written in mathematics but is there
something that breeds fire into the
equations or is the universe just the
equations are somehow isomorphic to them
so i guess i alluded to this earlier but
i think that last parenthetical
statement phrase that you're using
is really really crucial there because
i do think the universe is isomorphic to
some set of equations
i do not think that that's more or less
the same as saying the universe just is
the equations
the universe is the universe the
universe is suey generous the universe
is the unique universal thing i'm a
monist in that sense again i could be
talked out of it by evidence or
reasoning or whatever but as far as i
can tell
there's something called the universe
and it is the thing to try to explain
what it is
in other more primitive terms is a
fool's errand there are no more
primitive terms to use it's what exists
but we can describe it we can describe
it using equations using laws of physics
and there's nothing that breeds fire
into them they're just a language that
we use to describe the universe so the
universe is mathematical in the sense
that we use math to describe it but it's
not made of mathematics or anything like
that
as i said there are different versions
of mathematics what would it mean for
the universe to be made of mathematics
uh there are parts of the universe that
behave in ways for which mathematics is
a useful way of talking about them
that's how i would say it anonymous says
i've heard physicists say that time and
space switch roles inside of a black
hole i've also heard them say that the
whole universe is inside a black hole
are these statements true in some sense
no
neither one of those statements is true
in any sense sorry about that
um let's go to the first one time in
space switch roles inside of a black
hole just false just totally wrong what
does it what would that even mean
i don't know what that would mean what i
know why they say it i know what mistake
they're making but it is totally a
mistake the mistake they're making is
the following
um
when we do physics in space-time it is
very often to put coordinates on
space-time right to find things so to be
able to say where something is and when
something is happening we put
coordinates on space and coordinate on
time
uh so let's imagine that we do that
in a way that is naturally adapted to a
black hole to let's say the a simple
non-rotating short shield black hole
okay there's a very obvious version of
polar coordinates spherical coordinates
that works for a black hole and you have
time you have space they both
have certain distances in both time and
space that are described by the space
time metric okay
now let's say uh and and for all the our
purposes here um these coordinates are t
for time
r for the distance uh the radial
distance and then there's theta and phi
for the angles around some axis that you
pick and who cares about theta and phi
it's a spherically symmetric black hole
so really what we care about are t the
time coordinate and r the distance the
radial coordinate away from the black
hole
so here's a fun fact
if you naively
take those coordinates that you set up
outside the black hole and extend them
into the black hole
then what you are calling r the radial
coordinate becomes time like that is to
say increasing your value of r moves you
in a time-like direction not a space
like direction
and t what you were calling the
time-like coordinate becomes space-like
inside the black hole
that's a true statement
but hopefully
you can see the vast gulf in between
that true statement
and the very false statement that time
and space have switched roles
time and space didn't switch roles at
all we just chose a dopey coordinate
system that's all
don't reify your coordinate systems
don't take your coordinate systems too
seriously if you fell in
to a black hole it was a big black holes
you weren't being spaghettified or
anything like that you wouldn't even
notice that you were in a black hole
nothing happens when you cross the event
horizon you would think that if time and
space had switched their roles you would
notice
but in fact you don't uh you wouldn't be
using coordinates when you're just
floating around you would just be
falling in and waiting
until you hit the singularity the other
true statement is that the singularity
is not
to your left if you're in a black hole
it's to your future okay it is time like
separated from you but again
it always was it never was toward the
center whenever you were told the
singularity was at the center of a black
hole they were just lying to you you've
been lied to a lot i'm sorry about to
tell you that but the singularity is in
your future it's kind of like a big
crunch
so
the other half the whole universe is
inside a black hole no clearly not
because if that were true if we were
inside a black hole then guess what
there would be a singularity in our
future which would inevitably hit
there's no reason to think there's a
singularity in our future that we will
inevitably hit in fact the simplest
version of cosmology says the universe
will just continue to expand and
accelerate and empty out forever that
doesn't sound very much like a black
hole at all
but again there is a very dumb argument
that could lead you to believe that it
is namely the following
if you have enough matter
and you collect it into a region of
space and calculate its density and its
size
there is a conjecture that if you have
enough matter
in a region
it will have to collapse to a black hole
okay
and if you take a big enough part of the
universe it turns out we do have that
much matter so therefore shouldn't we be
collapsing to a black hole
well they lied to you again because it's
not true that if you get enough matter
you have to collapse to a black hole
it's true that if you get enough matter
you either
collapse to a singularity in the future
or
you came out of a singularity in the
past
guess what
we came out of a singularity in the past
which we call the big bang
if anything
the universe is like a white hole a
white hole just the time reversal of a
black hole which starts in a singularity
and spits things out it's not exactly
like a white hole either because there's
no event horizon around it as far as we
know but it's much more like a white
hole than it is a black hole the
universe is nothing like a black hole
roughly speaking
a sheikh dragoneel says what is
the universality of computation
are humans universal too i.e can humans
understand anything and everything in
the universe given in our limited
perception of the world
um well this is a subtle complicated
question and also sort of
at the periphery of my own knowledge so
maybe someone who knows better can chime
in um
there is an idea called the church
turing thesis so you can go google
church touring thesis these are two
people's names it's not the name of a
church
okay uh alonso church and alan turing
and the thesis is you know these are
mathematicians okay so they're gonna
phrase things precisely not vaguely like
we physicists would phrase them consider
computable functions
so you have some in fact make your life
easy make make things finite so rather
than functions of real numbers think of
functions of of uh integers okay
so there's some function from the
integers to other integers
and
some of these are calculatable
computable and some might not be like
you can invent a non-computable function
and what the church turing thesis says
is that if your function is computable
then it can be computed by a touring
machine a turing machine is just a
computer let's call it a computer this
would be simple right
now the church during thesis is not
proven as far as i know it's not
something that is absolutely established
but people think it's basically true
okay maybe maybe it has been proven i i
honestly don't know like i said it's not
in my uh wheelhouse but people treat it
as true
so what they're saying is that this
class of computable functions if it's
computable in one way a computer can
calculate it
that's a little bit far away from
the quality the phrase as you put it can
humans understand anything and
everything in the universe right well
you know if if we say number one that
the human brain is is a turing machine
if it has the capabilities of a turing
machine which i think is fair uh it
might not be very accurate turing
machine we make mistakes unlike a good
computer but we have the computational
capacity to be touring like
then in principle given time and enough
graph paper we can calculate all these
functions
that is not the same as saying we can
understand everything and everything in
the universe anything and everything in
the universe i don't even know what that
means understand anything and everything
in the universe
so something like discovering the
correct laws of physics
might not be equivalent to computing a
function right
um so there's sort of the rigorous
statement of the thesis and then there
is the sort of informal understanding
and the informal understanding is just
not that uh on on that firm ground uh
the informal understanding is once you
can compute things symbolically like a
computer then you can compute whatever
you want and and all the effort is all
the work is being done by the phrase
whatever you want
uh so i would be a little bit
um
careful let's put it that way uh i do
think that
you know i want to have it both ways
when i have my cake needed to on the one
hand
i think that the ability to do symbolic
computations
like a touring machine like a computer
is something that humans have and
something that earthworms do not
i think that there is some kind of phase
transition in our thinking ability that
happened along the evolutionary timeline
so that human beings can symbolically
manipulate things
can talk to each other using language
and words in ways that other
at least some other animals or plants
cannot and that gives us an ability to
calculate things that is above
that of earthworms um but that i don't
want to stretch that to anything and
everything so i don't know what exactly
that means maybe i just don't know let's
put it that way
okay varun narasimhachar says
why do you think our understanding of
quantum mechanics is incomplete i feel
we understand operationally just as well
as we do classical mechanics but seem to
insist on fitting it to our classical
intuition by adding unnecessary features
beyond what's operationally accessible
as for questions like what really exists
i think we had no meaningful answers in
classical mechanics either e.g does mass
exist do electric fields exist
i think it's pretty
straightforward why our understanding of
quantum mechanics is incomplete if you
look at
the textbook
explication of quantum mechanics you're
told things like
when a quantum system is measured its
wave function collapses and the collapse
is unpredictable it obeys the born rule
the probability is given by the wave
function squared etc okay
you're not told what it told what it
means to measure a quantum system
that's just left incomplete i'm not
saying it's not completable
but you're just not told what counts as
a measurement does a single photon
bumping into something qualify as a
measurement you need to be conscious to
do a measurement could a video camera do
it
how quickly does it happen when exactly
does it happen doing a measurement
now of course you can try to do better
what i'm saying is the textbook version
of quantum mechanics just leaves these
questions unanswered so that is clearly
incomplete there's just zero questions
zero controversy about the fact that
textbook quantum mechanics is not a
complete rigorous physical theory you
can try to fix it up you can say well
there's decoherence blah blah blah but
then what you discover
is that there are different ways to fix
it up and people don't agree on what the
right way is that's why you have bombing
mechanics in many worlds etc
the very fact that some people believe
bohmian mechanics and some other people
believe many worlds and some other
people believe objective collapse models
and we don't know which one is right
is right there a proof that we don't
understand quantum mechanics that our
understanding is incomplete if we did
have a complete understanding we would
know which of those is right if any of
them okay as for questions like what
really exists your two examples are does
mass exist and do electric fields exist
you know mass is not a thing it's a
property right mass energy momentum
these are properties that other things
have like electrons or electromagnetic
fields or whatever so mass you could
take it or leave it there's different
ways of describing the same physical
thing with using that property or not
but electric fields do they exist the
answer is yes
in classical electromagnetism that's a
very meaningful answer yes the electric
field exists i think that if you give up
on the idea of saying what exists then
you give up on the on the goal of
understanding the universe which is both
a very plausible goal and one we're
making great progress towards so that's
not a goal i'm going to give up on
anytime soon
kathy seeger says in your recent paper
consciousness and the laws of physics
you elaborated on the core theory you've
also made it clear what its domain of
applicability is
since frank wilcheck proposed the core
theory in 2015 and you endorsed it ever
since what's your impression did it gain
more attention and approval in the
physics community over time and does
does frank wilcheck approve of the way
you constructed the core theory equation
frank wilcheck of course yet another
previous mindscape guest um so let me be
clear about this because i don't want to
give too much credit to either me or to
frank wilcheck what frank wilcheck put
forward in 2015 was the name
the core theory and the core theory
itself
was already there it just didn't have a
name and you know the core theory is the
combination of the standard model of
particle physics and general relativity
thought of as a an effective field
theory in the weak field limit okay
so people knew before 2015 that that was
a perfectly sensible theory to talk
about frank's point was this is what you
need to understand the laws of physics
underlying everyday life and so he gave
it a name the core theory um
no one person invented it right it was
put together by many different people
including einstein
because general relativity came from him
and including frank wilczak because the
strong interactions you need to
understand asymptotic freedom to
understand them which was understood
first by gross pulitzer and wilcheck and
they won the nobel prize for that so
part of the core theory really is
frank's uh to his frank's credit but
there's also the weak interactions the
electroweak theory for whom the most
important person was stephen weinberg
who sadly just passed away
um but again many other people murray
gilman um richard feynman arguably
james clark maxwell gets credit because
you know he wrote down the uh
electromagnetic part of it etc dirac
obviously gets credit etc many many many
people contributed higgs you know
unclear and higgs and brow
um
so that was already there um so i don't
think that the physics community cares
like i mean they knew it already like
the the the existence of a new label for
it doesn't change their minds very much
but um so if you and i've done this
experiment i think maybe what you're
really getting at is if you go up to
someone who is a working physicist
who is an expert on quantum field theory
who really knows what you mean when you
talk about effective field theories and
the standard model etc and you say
what do you think about the claim
that if you take general relativity and
the standard model and combine them into
effective field theory
that qualifies as the laws of physics
underlying everyday life and we're you
know as we learn more and discover new
things in physics uh they won't have any
direct impact on everyday life uh people
will generally think about it for like
10 to 15 seconds and go yeah that sounds
right
so they haven't previously thought about
it generally but they don't object to it
either um
you asked as frank we'll check approve
of the way i constructed the core theory
equation you know yes but again i didn't
do anything it was already there it was
just writing things down that people
already uh had thought about
samuel benjamin says you've mentioned
many times that the words we use in
modern physics are poor descriptors of
the phenomena we observe wave function
being a particularly bad one although i
still have to think hard about the
various uses of the word space
have you ever come up with alternatives
for some of the more challenging terms
and phrases that you feel do a better
job at helping others understand the
concepts do you know of any other
languages that describe these concepts
better than english
so you know i have in different
moments but not very seriously like one
i talked about i think i talked about on
the podcast not too long ago was smooth
tension as an alternative to dark energy
uh but you know what it's just a joke i
wasn't serious and the reason why i was
not serious is because
you can't
really fight the battle of making sure
that all the words we use
are not only labels but also
definitions
right
words are labels when you say quantum
mechanics you mean a certain theory it
is not necessary that the theory be the
mechanics of quanta
when you say the theory of relativity
you mean a certain theory it is not
necessary that that theory really have
anything to do with one thing being
relative to another it's useful if they
are it's helpful but really it's a label
as long as you know what you mean that's
what matters
and maybe we would like to imagine a
perfect world of language and
representation where all words really
gave you an instantly correct idea what
they're referring to but that's not our
world that's not the world we live in
and the battle to clean up the language
so that things are more accurate is very
very hard uh to win
and you know maybe there's certain sort
of social justice examples where it's
worth fighting that battle but for
labeling physics theories it almost
never is uh and i don't think that any
uh other languages do any better but i
don't not really fluent enough in enough
other languages to know um
usually a language will just borrow
the name from whatever
language the original concept was
invented in so
languages tend to share the same
terminology for these kinds of things
okay last question comes from david de
klotz who says how do you decide when to
end a podcast episode
see what i'm doing there ending this
podcast episode with this question the
question is how do you decide when to
end a poscat podcast episode are guests
ever caught by surprise when you
suddenly say thanks for being on the
mindscape podcast or do you prepare them
in some way
um nope
they're never
they're never prepared uh maybe they're
caught by surprised i don't know i think
it's usually
uh
pretty clear that we're winding down i
mean maybe i'm wrong about that i don't
know um
but you know i've been on other uh
podcasts myself more than uh enough
times to have been on the other side of
the microphone um and you know yeah
usually you get a feeling like very
often as you'll hear
in the podcast i will give little clues
that were winding down right like i
won't usually say this is
sorry i shouldn't say that sometimes i
say this is the last question but what i
realize is it's often not true so i try
not to say that what i will try to say
is something like you know coming to the
end or you know the last topic last
thing i wanted to talk about is because
there's very often follow-up questions
right um so sometimes i do that other
times you know there's a
set of things that are natural to talk
about and we're coming to the end of
them
other times
they've been like a tiny number of times
when the guest has really wanted to keep
talking
usually you know look an hour plus
podcast is a long time and i'm talking
to busy people some people like to talk
forever stephen wolfram would have kept
talking but you know it was past 10 pm
my time and like past midnight his time
when we were doing that podcast so i
don't have the energy to keep going
after two and a half hours
and most people like once you hit an
hour there is something natural about an
hour even though it's an arbitrary human
invention
we're trained or socialized to do things
for an hour tv shows right movies
whatever hour hour and a half makes
sense to us
after that
seminars you know after that you begin
to fade so i think people are ready uh
to wind things up you know so i'll give
you two examples of counter examples one
is jeffrey west
one of my first podcast guests um
uh you can go listen it's like the
in the top in the one of the in the
first ten podcasts i did jeffrey west
might be like five or six and jeffrey is
great and one of the things that is
great about him is he can talk forever
and so just get him talking i i told him
i was new i was naive and uh i said look
we have plenty of time we have over an
hour
but the mistake was uh
we
that was when i was visiting the santa
fe institute where jeffrey is a
professor and i was scheduled to be at a
public event in santa fe at a certain
time later that evening and i literally
like had to leave
so i had to you know had to wrap it up
we had gone over for over an hour and
jeffrey was like i didn't even get to
talk about sustainability i want to talk
about that like well okay i gotta go i
gotta be on stage so that was one
example
um the other example was kip thorne
who said you know i thought you were
gonna ask me about what it is like to
win the nobel prize and i had a good
answer
all set for that and i said yeah i don't
care what it's like to win the nobel
prize i care about black holes and
gravitational waves and time travel um
but he said you know it's the one time
when someone said well could you ask it
to me now you're done if you ask it to
me now and edit it in so i did that so i
don't know if it's noticeable um but in
that podcast there's a time in the
middle where we're talking about the
nobel prize
which i actually which actually was
recorded at the end and then i edited it
in and it's not just because it's not at
all because kip wanted to sort of bask
in the glory of winning the nobel prize
he actually wanted to critique the whole
process he had thoughts about how it
could be better in its shortcomings so
um
and i always do ask
if i remember but which is almost always
the case when i finish a podcast uh
finish the recording i say
did we miss anything i ask the you know
the guest and usually they say oh we
covered a lot that's good
so i'm not i don't think that we're um
leaving a lot of things out you know
there's certain certain people have a
lot to say certain people have a thing
that they're going to say in the same in
different ways over and over again so
different people are good but you know
most of the people who i've had on the
podcast i could talk for longer i and
some and famously there are other
podcasts that go on longer than i do but
as i've said before you know i
am very
um gratified that the kind of people who
i get on the podcast come on at all
uh i think i get really really good
people
some people are even better than others
but the overall quality of people i get
is very gratifying to me i'm very happy
with it and they're very busy people and
i don't want to take up too much of
their time right um
uh i've had people say well like
normally i say no to podcasts but for
you all say yes and that puts a lot of
pressure on me to like try to make it a
good podcast and try not to waste their
time in any way so almost all the people
i talk to
have much more to say that is
interesting than we get to cover in the
podcast but there is a limit to what is
sort of appropriate
and with that we've reached the end of
this podcast this ama thanks have a good
month
hopefully our
pandemic continues to evaporate and we
can return to normality again take care
bye
[Music]
you